So, wieder da? Ja, okay. Ist wieder da. Und die VM geht auch. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was
Windows wieder gedacht hat, was nicht funktioniert. Windows-Logik. Das sind so Sachen. So Probleme
hast du unter Linux echt nicht. Im Zweifelsfall schießt du unter Linux mal was ab, nutzt dich
mal funktionierten, startest, dann gehts wieder. Aber so ist voll der Witz. Wo du dich den ganzen
anderen müssen auch starten. Hast du schon Discord gelesen, was ich geschafft habe, Nesebaro?
Soll ich da jetzt reingucken und onstream? Das ist das, äh, muss man das der Welt mitteilen?
Meinst du? Ja, gut, mach ich gleich auf. Ach im Admin-Channel, im Admin-Channel guck
ich lieber nicht im Stream rein, wer weiß was da sonst noch so drin steht. Nix Böses,
ah, gut, dann gucken wir rein. So, jetzt ist alles gestartet, wunderbar. Kranios. Hat
der nur eine Reboot gebraucht? Ach ne, das Pepega-Board fehlt noch. Das ist ja eigentlich
das, was ich starten wollte. Oh man. Darf ich, darf ich mal nen Browser verwenden, irgendwie?
Der POG-Chat, den haben wir letztens gefunden. Gut, ähm, das hat jetzt 10 Minuten oder so
gedauert, weil Windows der Meinung war, abzuspatten. Dann starten wir das und können jetzt anfangen,
aber vorher muss ich noch mal in den Admin-Channel gucken, dass wir uns anschauen können, was
da Sebaro für grandiose neue Errungenschaften, ähm, der Welt mitteilen muss. Ah, auf, starte
mal. Go, go, go. Der Friseur muss mal mehr streamen, der streamt kaum noch. Auch wenn
das Video nicht so mein Game ist, ich guck dem immer gerne zu, wenn er da irgendwie 8
Stunden im Kreis grindet. Aber er streamt irgendwie so wenig. Ich hab schon ein Profil
zum Runnen, ich brauch kein neues. So, jetzt. Gut. Ja, der Windows Neustart hat mich über
ein bisschen durcheinander gebracht. Ok, gucken wir mal ins Discord. Also, was gibt's denn
da Neues? Übrigens, ähm, wer den Link noch nicht hat, Ausrufezeichen Discord. Gibt's
einen Invite-Link. Yo, Max, lohnt sich ein Upgrade von einer 150 TI auf eine 1660 TI.
Also, ich denk mal, dass der schon ordentlich Leistung bringen wird. Ich kenn jetzt keine
Benchmarks, können wir gleich mal gucken. E-Mathmen-Channel. Und du meinst, Sebaro,
ich kann da reingucken, ohne dass da jetzt was Schlimmes drin steht, ja? Ok. Und jetzt?
Du hast LXD-Container eingerichtet. Max, wie machst du noch mal deine VMs in Linux?
Das ist LXD. Das benutzt standardmäßig alle Cores. Hä? Kannst du mal kurz mein Profil
sein? Nee, kann ich nicht, weil ich nicht eingeloggt bin in Steam hier auf dem, auf
dem Account. Ich kann's aber nachher machen, wenn du willst. Du hast viele Benachrichtigungen
beim Discord. Ja, weil ich, äh, ich setz' die nie auf gelesen. Ich lass' die immer
einfach laufen. So, ähm, im Prinzip könnte man den ganzen Kram von gestern mal löschen.
Ja, dann ein leeres Pipiga-Board haben. Gut. Ja, nice, nice, nice Sebaro. Das, äh, ist
glaub' ich gar nicht so schwierig da, äh, Multi-Cores drinnen zu verwenden. Ich glaub',
es macht sogar standardmäßig schon. So, also, nachdem wir ja gestern nicht zu der Geschichte
mit Nextcloud gekommen sind, machen wir das heute. Und das ist auch der Grund, warum ich
unbedingt mal ein Linux-VM brauche, weil ohne die Linux-VM funktioniert das Ganze natürlich
nicht. Ähm, jetzt muss ich erstmal gucken, ob ich meinen Raspberry schon am Strom dran
hab' von gestern noch. Oder nicht. Nein, der hängt hier, der hängt hier neben rum,
aber ist nicht am Stromstrand, Stromblub, Strom dran. Muss ich erst mal anschließen.
Warum steckt man USB immer falsch rum ein? So, jetzt. Heute geht das Roasten weiter.
Wollen wir heute dann zum Schluss noch mal ein paar Stellenanzeigen angucken, ob wir
wieder ein bisschen was zum Flamen finden. Da war ja gestern, also ich muss sagen, die
erste Stellenanzeige, die wir gesehen haben, die war echt okay, der Rest war ziemlicher
Blödsinn. So, da ist er. Ähm, ich hole mal eine SSD und stöpsel die an den Raspberry
dran. Eats SSD Eats Life. Oh nee, der bricht das schlecht um. Ich hole mal kurz eine SSD
und stöpsel die an, dass wir das nachher auch ordentlich testen können. Weil, mit der
On-Board im MicroSD-Karte ist für'n Arsch. Da habe ich hier meinen Shima USB 3 auf SATA-Adapter.
Für die Testwerke reicht der. Wie willst du was falsch einstecken? Nee, gar nicht.
Man hat immer USB falsch rum. Ich hab das immer falsch rum am ersten Versuch. Okay,
haben die ne schöne Anleitung dazu? Ähm, also Sebaro, wenn du mit LXC alle Cores auslassen
kannst, dann müsstest du direkt auf dem Server auch alle Cores auslassen können. Oder meinst
du, weil du so mehrere Sachen parallel laufen lassen kannst. So, den USB-C-Porn, den USB-C-Porn,
da haben sie ja immer was Gescheites gemacht, ja. Den kannst du so rum und so rum einstecken,
das ist doch mal was. Bei waagrechten Steckplätzen muss das Loch des Steckers immer raus, kann
man sagen, also sind keine waagrechten Steckplätze an meinem Gehäuse und ich guck mir die Stecker
immer nicht an. Es geht fast schneller, einfach immer rumdrehen und meistens ist es ja bei
USB so, erster Versuch passt nicht, zweiter Versuch passt nicht, dritter Versuch, erster
Versuch hätte doch gepasst. Ja, das kannst du machen Sebaro. Du kannst aber einfach auf
dem Host mehrere Sachen starten. So, haben die eine offizielle Anleitung für Debian,
wie man das installiert, weil die Sache ist die, man braucht bestimmt zig PHP-Abhängigkeiten
und da müssen wir erstmal gucken, welche das sind. Macht's überhaupt Bock nur für
162, das wäre noch ein bisschen mehr klein. Meistens sind da so, haben wir dann so meistens
so 100 bis 150 in dem Dreh. Haben die irgendwie eine ordentliche Anleitung? Nee, haben die
nicht, oder? Download Server, ja schön. Gibt es denn vielleicht ein, gibt es schon ein fertiges
Raspbian Xcloud Repo? Vielleicht brauchen wir das dann gar nicht, dann macht das das
alles für mich. Criga, hat nichts mit dem Krieger zu tun, glaube ich. Lies sich aber
ähnlich. Install Engineings, also wir machen das weder mit Redis noch mit MariaDB, wir machen
das mit einem SQLite Server zum Testen. Braucht man überhaupt einen externen Web Service,
Web Server für Nextcloud, haben die nicht? Irgendso einen Dev Server mit dabei, den man
Windows. Gibt es Leute, die betreiben das auf Windows? Sachen gibt's. Machen das wirklich
Leute, ja? Install via Snap, das könnten wir tatsächlich machen. Das ist easy as fucke
mit Snap zu installieren, aber wenn wir es mit Snap installieren, könnten wir es auch
gleich als Docker Package installieren. Example Installation, ich will das irgendwann von
Hand draufhauen. Es gibt ein fertiges Steam Account Signing. Ja doch, wie gesagt, ich
kann es jetzt hier auf dem Stream nicht machen, aber ich mach das. Am besten ist, ihr schreibt
das irgendwo auf dem Discord. Ich weiß ja nicht genau wo, ob wir da vielleicht mal im
Discord für sowas einen eigenen Channel machen. Also ich kann das schon prinzipiell machen,
aber wir müssen es irgendwo speichern. Vielleicht machen wir das im Discord. Vielleicht machen
wir im Discord einen eigenen Channel für sowas. Da könnt ihr das rein posten und dann kann
ich das machen. Warum werden Server denn auf Linux gehostet? Also mal ganz pauschal gesagt,
würde ich sagen, zum größten Teil, weil es erstens umsonst ist, zweitens viel mehr
Auswahl hat an Server-Anwendungen, die was taugen, weil die Administration remote deutlich
einfacher ist, weil man das besser automatisieren kann, weil es open source ist, was ja auch
ein gewisser Faktor ist, wenn es um Security-Geschichten geht, und weil so ziemlich jeder 0815 Service
im Internet auf Linux läuft. Also man hat einfach auch die Leute, die sich damit auskennen.
Wenn man Sachen unter Windows hostet, dann macht man das meistens nur, wenn es eine
Sache ist, die es exklusiv für Windows gibt, oder als halt eine Support-Geschichte ist für
Windows-Clients. Also sprich, wenn man sagt, man hat 50 Windows-Clients und will einen
Active Directory haben oder sowas, dann, aber das ist was, da kann es mich nichts zu fragen,
weil von Windows habe ich keine Ahnung, und dann nimmt man sich halt auch einen Windows-Server
und macht da AD drauf, weil ich meine, man kann zwar AD auch mit Samba machen, aber ich
glaube jemand, der ernsthaft einen AD betreiben will, macht das nicht mit Samba, dann macht
das mit einem Windows-Server. Zumindest würde ich das so machen. Allerdings würde ich
keine AD betreiben und kein Windows-Server, aber es ist was anderes. So, also, Demian-Packages.
All you can use that package to install... Ah ja, hier steht es doch, was man braucht.
Wir gucken uns lieber die Anleitung von dem Typ an mit Nginx, das wäre lieber. Ich bin
kein großartiger Apache-Fan. Was macht der denn hier? MariaDB lassen wir weg. Nginx-Config
scheint mir ziemlich übertrieben zu sein. Machen wir mal die offizielle Anleitung, wir
können das ja immer noch ändern. Wo waren wir gerade? Da. Also Maria, lassen wir weg.
Also, das brauchen wir alles. Ohne MariaDB. Ich hoffe die Option, dass man das mit sqlite
laufen lassen kann, gibt es noch. Wie unser Discord in Whitelink, der geht nicht auf den
Weep-Channel, der geht auf die Eingangshalle. Oder? Ihr müsstet eigentlich automatisch
in die Eingangshalle kommen, wenn man automatisch in den Weep-Channel kommt, dann wundert es
mich nicht, dass die Leute direkt wieder rausgehen. Oh, aus dem Ball-Roll. Jaja, das musste ändern.
Geht auf den Weep-Channel. Geil. Nein, so war das glaub ich nicht gedacht. Ist in xcloud
16 eigentlich schon Produkt, ja. Also das ist rausgekommen schon vor 3 Monaten oder so.
Das kam sogar schon am 25.04. raus. Jetzt sollte es richtig, ja. Oh, der Created noch
Dinger im Hintergrund, ok. Wir sollten mal, wir sollten mal die SSD ein File-System drauf
machen. Ich gerade angeschlossen, mal gucken, ob der Respirator die erkennt. Wurde der Web-Based-Updater
wieder rausgeholt? Hoffentlich nicht. Nextcloud war schon, oder generell auch damals bei Oncloud
war das immer so ein Acti-Sache zu updaten. Und sie hätten ja die Chance gehabt, mal
ein ordentliches Docker-Image zu machen damals, aber irgendwie hatten sie ein Docker-Image,
was man selbst nicht updaten kann, was ja eigentlich so... Was jetzt? Achso, ich glaube,
das liegt daran, weil wir schon, weil wir schon Nginx drauf installiert haben. Wir installieren
mal kurz. Und dann geht der Apache wahrscheinlich auch. Dann bin ich mal gespannt, was sich
da in 3 Versionen alles getan hat. Wie gesagt, ich habe bei mir ja noch 13 drauf. Und das
hat mir nicht so gut gefallen. Vor allem, weil der Sync rumgebackt hat oftmals. Ich
hatte relativ oft, obwohl mehr als 5 Minuten Zeit waren, wo ich die Dateien abgerufen
habe, habe ich dann irgendwelche Sync-Konflikte gekriegt und sowas. War sehr merkwürdig.
Was? Nein. The Game im Discord ist... Ich meine anderes. Das bin ich nicht. Sync-Konflikte
Bild-Dios? Nee. Sync-Konflikte bei meinen Plain-Text-Notizen hat da rumgespackt, wo
ich mir gedacht habe, das ist so ziemlich der simpelste Fall, den man irgendwie haben
kann, Plain-Text-Notiz zu sünden. Da kann es eigentlich keine Probleme geben. Viel einfacher
geht es ja nicht. The Poplar ist am Start. Ich finde das interessant, wenn man auf Science
and Technology stellt, den die Kategorie... Also im Vergleich zu... Im Prinzip gibt es
ja nur zwei Kategorie, die du machen kannst. Science and Technology oder Just Chatting.
Just Chatting hast du viel mehr random Leute, die dem Stream dann so über den Weg laufen.
Und im Durchschnitt hast du in Just Chatting auch deutlich mehr Views. Allerdings hat man
in Science and Technology hat man zwar weniger Views, allerdings nach einem Stream mehr neue
Follower. Das ist interessant, ja. Wahrscheinlich weil in die Kategorie auch Leute gucken,
die es interessiert und die andere nur Leute, die mal vorbeikommen und dann ein bisschen
gucken. Ist nicht... Merkwürdig. Man wird eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass die Kategorie,
wo man im Durchschnitt auch die meisten Zuschauer kriegt, dann auch unterm Strich dann das meiste
gibt, aber anscheinend nicht. Warum gibt es keinen Pokchamp in Dynamis? Das gibt es doch.
Es gibt doch eh so ein paar Main Viewer. Ja, es gibt Leute, die sind immer am Start, das
gibt es auch. Oder hatte ich das jetzt schon? Installs, the packages, blablabla. Now download
Archive Nextcloud Version, go to blablabla, blablabla. Gut, machen wir gleich. Erstmal
müssen wir die Festplatte formatieren, also die SSD. Und wir müssen mal gucken, ob wir
den Apache... Wie heißt er unter Debian? Apache? Apache 2? Aha, ok. Schauen wir mal,
ob die Webseite prinzipiell funktioniert. It works. Sehr schön. Ok, die Nextcloud machen
wir allerdings auf die SSD drauf, weil ich habe jetzt auch keine Lust beim Testen meiner
Micro SD Karte Aschen wie kaputt zu machen. Zeig mal, was haben wir denn hier für eine
SSD? Da, da ist sie. Ja, DEV SDA. Dann haben wir noch MKFS, AXE. Ach komm, wir machen XFS
an. Wow, Raspberry, was ist los? Another Voltage detected. Das sieht es auf jeden Fall
nicht so gut. Vielleicht sollte ich den Raspberry mal direkt an die Steckdose, also direkt mit
einem Spin-Netzteil an die Steckdose anstöpseln, anstatt es an den Rechner zu hängen. Egal,
solange er nicht abkackt, wird das schon verkraften. 100 Grad, wo hast du das jetzt gelesen? VC,
53 Grad ist er. Das ist beim Raspberry Pi 4 gar nicht so abwegig, das Ding wird ja heiß
ohne Ende. Wir hatten es ja mal ausprobiert, auf wie viel haben wir es gekriegt? 86 Grad
oder so? Ohne Lüfter? Also ohne Kühlkörper und ich glaube, 81 Grad mit Kühlkörper oder
sowas. Also das Ding ist richtig warm geworden. Huge warm ist das. Massive warm. Ich werde
jetzt einmal die Nextcloud-Geschichte hier auspacken und gucken, ob es so prinzipiell
funktioniert. Und dann installieren wir das nochmal neu auf die SSD. Muss ich achte Check
oder brauche eine Check-Summe? Gut, einfach anzippen hier drinnen und gut ist. Zack. Boah,
der anzippt sich aber ganz schön ab. Hätte ich doch nicht auf der MicroSD gerade anzippen
sollen. Es gibt eine fertige Manjaro-Version mit i3, ist das eine andere als deine? Ja,
ich habe die minimalen Installationen, die minimalen Netinstall-Versionen und habe den
Rahmen selbst eingerichtet, ja. Ok, slash, Nextcloud. Ui, was? But why? Haha, jetzt kommen
tolle Apache-Debug-Geschichten. Habe ich irgendwas vergessen zu machen? Das ist immer
so. Beste. Datei-Berechtigung, ja wahrscheinlich. Irgendwie sowas. Irgendwie sowas. Ich denke
mal, das muss WWW-Data gehören und nicht root. WWW-Data, wobei ist das auch überhaupt
unter Raspian so? Wahrscheinlich. Wir gucken mal, als was läuft in der Web-Server. WWW-Data,
ok, dann ergibt das Sinn. Ja, ja. Bam. Nochmal. Jetzt gehts wahrscheinlich. Ey. Only my SQL
is available. Moment, ich will nicht mal SQL, ich will SQLite. Da muss man wahrscheinlich
SQLite Zeug installieren. SQLite. Wie heißt die Pakete, die man da installieren muss?
SQLite, PHP, wir suchen einfach mal. SQLite, was gibt es denn da alles? Gibt es eigentlich
ein Eats-Tool, mit dem man mit ein paar Klicks, ein simple Web-Server, Web-Server. Ich kann
es nicht richtig vorlesen, aber ich kann dir die Frage beantworten. Ja, gibt es. Total
easy. Du kannst einfach sagen. Fuck, ich hab's nicht mehr in der History. Du kannst mit
Python mit einer Zeile, kannst den Web-Server starten. Das ist total einfach. Simple HTTP.
Genau. Ja, so. Ach so. Also mal angenommen, hier bist du jetzt in dem Ordner drin und
willst einfach alle Dateien zur Verfügung stellen, die... Bin ich jetzt bescheuert?
Ach so, ok. Gehst einfach rein, führst das aus und schon hast du einen Web-Server auf
Port 80 laufen, auf Port 8000 laufen. Zack, hast du hier alle Dateien. Das ist halt sehr
rudimentär und simple, aber für statisches HTML reicht das voll und ganz aus. So, und
wie sah die Python 3-Variante aus? Sehr Overflow. Ah ja, ok, die Python 3-Variante
ist das hier. Würde ich bevorzugen. Wow. Oder auch nicht. Ach so, der Punkt kommt ja
dahinter. So. Oder auch nicht. Lassen wir den Punkt einfach mal weg. Ok, so geht's auch.
Das ist super einfach und so Sachen gibt's für fast alle Sprachen, die irgendwie dabei
sind. Also Rubidrubi kannst du sowas machen, mit PAP kannst du sowas machen, so ein einfach
ganz... Node kannst du auch einfach in den Server starten. Aber ich finde die Python-Sache
ist am einfachsten, weil man kann sich eigentlich ganz gut merken, also wahrscheinlich kann
sich das jeder merken außer... Außer ich, dass man einfach sagen muss, minus M-HTTP-Server
und gut ist. Ich mein, viel kürzer und aussagekräftiger kann's eigentlich nicht sein in statischen
HTTPS-Server aufzumachen, der in dem Ordner statisches HTML Zeug surft. Ok, SQLite, PAP,
was muss ich denn da alles installieren für, was funktioniert? Oh man, bruh. Abinstall,
hier, PHP, PHP, SQLite. Wartet mal Leute, hab... Ich hab übelst Mist installiert, warum
hab ich denn hart... Siehste, deswegen copy-pastet man keine Tutorials. Warum hab ich PHP 7.2
installiert, warum hab ich nicht einfach normal PHP installiert, ohne so eine Versionsangabe
dabei, ist doch total beknackt. Einfach so, dass das Meta-Package installieren und dann
nimmt er halt das, was am aktuellsten ist. Ist der Tutorial klicken, ist nicht immer
das Richtige. Jetzt muss ich auch zur PAP-Version passende MySQL installieren, äh, SQLite installieren.
So, und dann reloaden wir und hoffen, dass das Ding gecheckt hat, dass wir auch SQLite
haben. Ne, da muss man wahrscheinlich, vielleicht muss man Apache restarten, dass er das kapiert,
oder? Wey! SQLite, jawoll. Also, Username, Admin, Passwort 123456. Also, äh, Massive
secure Passwort. Very weak. Das glaubt ja auch nur der Installer. Ah, hier kann man
das Datadirectory ändern. Das ändern wir mal, wobei das Datadirectory muss wahrscheinlich
unterhalb. Das probieren wir mal aus. Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Ähm, wir haben,
wir haben die SSD, haben wir formatiert, das passt. Wir mounten die jetzt mal. Dev-Sda-Sort.
Gucken wir mal rein, er dürfte außer Lost and Found, ah ne, noch nicht mal. Ist ja ein
XFS. Okay, dann, dann lassen wir das jetzt einfach mal da reinhauen. Wahrscheinlich müssen
wir die Berechtigung noch anpassen. Haben wir für Berechtigung. Root, Root, ja, okay,
das geht nicht. Dann, dann ändern wir das mal. Wobei, wir machen, wir machen, ey, scheiß
drauf. Jetzt zum Ausprobieren. So, slash, MNT, ähm, finish. Dann speicher, dann nehm
ich meine Sachen, die ich gleich zum Testen mal sünke. Speicher, dann nehm ich wenigstens
gleich auf der SSD. Und, dann kriegt meine Micro SD-Karte nicht so viel ab. Was macht
der da eigentlich gerade? Dinge macht er. Er macht 100% CPU-Dinge. Dann lassen wir immer
Dinge machen in der Zwischzeit. Gucken wir mal zu, ne. Aber es bleibt mir nix anderes
übrig. Die Musik passt auch voll dazu. Resident-Sleeper-Musik. Brauchen wir eigentlich was anderes. Sweet Jazz.
Ohje, das ist, das ist bestimmt Fahrstuhl. Das ist Fahrstuhl. Woop, woop, woop.
Overwatch-Summer-Music. Ich kenn bloß noch, ich kenn bloß noch die Overwatch-Weihnachts-Musik.
Ohja, genau. Äh, welcher Browser ist das hier? Das ist ganz normal. Chromium, Chromium ist
es. Ich hab so viele Browser installiert. Den fällt auch nix mal ein, oder? Im Prinzip
machen sie gefühlt seit, seit 3 Jahren. Und wann kamen Overwatch raus? 2017. Den gleichen
Kram. Wir brauchen Anime-Chills. Selbst die Baro Nu vielleicht. Aber, dass wir das brauchen,
habe ich immer eine Zweifel. Okay, es ist anscheinend ist installt. Save form for all your data.
Blabla, blabla. Auch guck mal, die haben jetzt einen, die haben jetzt so einen Setup-Guide,
wie es aussieht. Okay, das ist im Prinzip blabla. Blabla, blabla. Get Desktop-App. Ja,
die Desktop-App installieren wir gleich. Start using Nextcloud. Sehr schön. Äh,
die Desktop-App installieren wir jetzt mal. 11 ist es hier, der da. Cute-Keychain. Cute-Chat.
Haha, nee, nee.
Wobei, das muss ich mir mal angucken. Die Seite sieht gar nicht so schlecht aus. Kenne ich
noch gar nicht hier. Wie funktioniert das? Plug DJ. Select your favorite type of music
in Startlisten. Okay, Metal. Und jetzt? Ach, ach nee, ach so ist das. Man macht da, man
macht quasi einen Chatraum. Man macht quasi so eine Art Chatraum. Und wenn man da jetzt
Musik reinzieht, hören das alle, die drin sind, oder wie? Das ist eigentlich gar keine
schlechte Idee. Allerdings scheint die Plattform nicht so sonderlich besucht zu sein, ne? Hä,
ich mach mal da jetzt keinen Account. Aber ich überlege mal das mal. Ich finde, das
ist eigentlich eine gute App-Idee. Okay, Nextcloud ist installiert, das war super easy. Eats,
das war hier, meint Eats. Und es war, nein, das war's. Okay, es sieht immer noch so aus
wie eh und je. Und Nextcloud ist langsam von der SD-Karte. Da hätte ich aber auch selbst
drauf kommen können, ehrlich gesagt. Das machen wir jetzt noch mal anders. Ich lösch
den Scheiß noch mal. Lösch den Kram noch mal und hänge mal meine SSD an die Stelle
ein, wo Nextcloud gerade ist. Machen wir hier nicht verzeichnen, Nextcloud. Gucken wir,
ob das überhaupt dann gescheit funktioniert. Machen wir erst mal hier Temp. Dann unmounten
wir wieder die normale SSD, wobei das geht wahrscheinlich nicht, solange ich das anhabe.
Und dann moveen wir das ganze mal. Gucken, ob das funktioniert. Unmount die SSD, zack,
mont die SSD auf Temp. Und jetzt kopieren wir einfach den ganzen Mist. Wobei, ne, wir
können einfach den ganzen Kram moveen. Der hier drunter liegt, den moveen wir nach TMP.
Und dann sollte der Kram auf der SSD sein. Joa. Sieht so aus, ne? Und da sollte leer
sein. Achso, den Kram sollte man vielleicht noch mitschieben, das wäre nicht verkehrt.
Was suchst du, was suchst du Knäb? Ok, Nextcloud. Schmeißen wir mal weg. Here is the directory,
ja ja, blablabla. Alter, was ist das für Musik? Das hört sich irgendwie permanent
an. Ja. So, haben wir den Kram unmountet. Dann benennen wir das um, den mountpoint,
nextcloud. So, machen sie hier auch nochmal drauf. Und dann mounten wir den Kram wieder
und dann sollte das eigentlich genauso wieder funktionieren. Fsda nach nextcloud. Und jetzt
starten wir den Apache neu und gucken, ob alles funktioniert. Wenn ich es richtig gemacht
habe, sollte es wieder funktionieren. Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass mein data directory
ja immer noch verkehrt ist. Ja, mein data directory ist jetzt verkehrt. Ok Max, das
war doch keine allzu clevere Idee, was du da gemacht hast. Also muss ich die gerade nochmal
einstellen. Man kann das hier doch bestimmt drin einstellen. Config. Einstellen, wo das
data directory liegt, oder? Ach, da. Easy as a fuck. Mein data directory soll jetzt
das da sein. Übrigens, krasse Wim-Hacks jetzt mal an der Stelle. Was man machen kann, wenn
man einfach das da löschen will zwischen den einfachen Anführungsstrichen, sagt man
einfach ci. Einfache Anführungsstriche. Äh, warum hat das jetzt nicht funktioniert? Man
muss da nicht drin sein normalerweise. ci. Einfache Anführungsstriche. Was? Normalerweise
muss man da nicht drin sein. Ja, da funktioniert es auch so. So, da ist mein data directory.
Ok, gucken wir mal, ob meine nextcloud Installation wieder funktioniert. Oh, ich habe es kaputt
gemacht. Leute, ich habe es zerstört. Ich habe es kaputt gemacht. Lohnt. Mag der nicht,
dass das aufnimmt? Kann das sein, dass ich mich verschrieben habe? Nee, habe ich nicht.
Wie genau habe ich das jetzt geschafft, kaputt zu machen? Ja. Ok, ich setze nochmal die Dateiberechtigung
für alles da drauf. Aber nicht verkehrt. Ich habe es kaputt gemacht, Leute. RIP. Ich
muss nochmal neu installieren. Ich habe es zerstört. Ich bin mir ehrlich gesagt aber
nicht so ganz sicher, mit was ich es zerstört habe. Aber anscheinend habe ich es zerstört.
Na gut. Machen wir es halt nochmal. Ist ja nicht so, dass wir schon viel gemacht hätten.
So, wir haben jetzt einen Ordner. Nextcloud. Ja, ok. Stoppen wir mal den Apache, das ist
gleich nicht verkehrt. Ja, das war jetzt natürlich total episch. Ich muss da rein, es bringt
nichts, wenn ich den Ordner lösche. Ich habe gerade meinen Mountpoint gelöscht. Da hängen
geblieben. Ich muss jetzt erstmal da rein, erstmal alles löschen. Dann den Kram nochmal
da rein installieren. Jetzt ist alles weg, genau. Apache ist gestoppt. Gut. Weiß jemand
aus dem Kopf, wie man anzip sagt, dass er das hier rein anzippen soll, ohne den Ordner
zu erstellen. Geht doch bestimmt, da muss ich es danach nicht verschieben. Minus D.
Ja gut, dann, vielleicht geht das ja. Und zipp. Nextcloud. 16. Minus D. Ob das so funktioniert?
Jetzt macht der Nextcloud den Nextcloud, das ist natürlich total bescheuert. Aber man
merkt, dass es auf die SSD geht, weil das ist schon gleich viel schneller. Oder ist
es? G-Warp gemountet. Ja. Jetzt habe ich Nextcloud in Nextcloud, das ist natürlich super. Ganz,
ganz huge. Kann man nicht alles von Nextcloud einfach moveen? Dahin? Ne, das wird, das funktioniert
natürlich so nicht. Aber das müsste eigentlich funktionieren. Oh, geht doch. Big brain. Okay,
gut. Und jetzt tut es hoffentlich. Ey. Ach so, die Berechtigungen sind immer noch verkehrt.
Ja, die Berechtigungen sind, das können wir jetzt einfach fixen damit und jetzt gehts.
Ey. Admin, Passwort 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Finish. Jetzt rödel da wieder ein bisschen rum. Sollte
jetzt schneller gehen, weil es ist auf der SSD drauf. Da hat Twitch schon was zur Partnerbewerbung
gesagt. Ich hab die immer neu abgeschickt. Ich muss erst nochmal YouTube connecten zu
Twitch. Dass die auch sehen, dass ich, ich hab Twitter schon connectet und ich muss YouTube
noch connecten. Ja, Sebaro, so ist das. Warum bin ich eigentlich der Einzige, der irgendwie
dazu gedrängt wird, dass man Geld ausgeben darf. Bei allen anderen schreien die Leute,
Alter, sell out, sell out. Und bei mir ist es so, Max, ich will Geld, äh, Max, ich will
dir Geld geben, mach Partner. So, jetzt aber, jetzt hat es funktioniert. Alle anderen haben
keine Keks-Emotes. Ich hab ja auch noch, noch nicht, aber das ist wahrscheinlich eines
der ersten Emotes, die wir dann machen. Allerdings nehm ich nicht meinen Standard-Keks. Ich muss
mir mit Emotes eh noch was einfallen lassen. Erstens brauch ich jemanden, der gute Emotes
machen kann, der nicht gar so teuer ist, weil letztendlich, ich bin schon bereit dafür
was zu bezahlen. Also ich will ihnen auch was geben, weil, ähm, es ist immer, wie gesagt,
von Exposure kann keiner leben und hier ist jetzt nicht so, dass es auf Twitch wahnsinnig
viel wäre bei mir. Ähm, und ich brauch aber noch irgendein gescheites Konzept, wie man,
wie die Emotes aussehen sollen. Ok, also, Zeug funktioniert, gut. Du kannst mir Shit-Emotes
machen for free. Also, es gibt Channels, die werden nur abonniert, weil sie Shit-Emotes
haben. Vielleicht soll ich das auch probieren. So, wir brauchen erst noch mal einen neuen
User. Wir brauchen einen neuen, wie ging das, nochmal einen neuen User. Ja. Users. Wir brauchen
einen neuen User. Einen MonkaSmoke brauch ich auf jeden Fall, allerdings ist MonkaSmoke
kein offizielles Twitch-Emote. Da mache ich einen, da reichen wir einen BetterTwitchTV-Emote
oder sowas ein, weil ein Channel, der wupplos heißt, darf natürlich kein Emote global
auf Twitch machen oder generell auf Twitch machen, das MonkaSmoke heißt. Das ist ja
irgendwo klar. Wobei wir für MonkaSmoke schon das beste Emote überhaupt haben. Übrigens
wisst ihr, was mir gerade angefallen ist? Da müsst ihr euch schon mal Gedanken zu machen.
Wir haben ja schon unsere BetterTwitchTV-Emotes, allerdings, wir können auch noch 24 FFZ-Emotes
machen. Wie ist denn bei euch so die Verteilung? Was habt ihr denn? Also, Moment, da müssen
wir jetzt mal eine Abstimmung machen. Also, ja, ja, ihr müsst das doch nicht in Chatter.
Habt ihr ein Twitch-Addon? FFZ, BetterTwitchTV oder keins? Also, ich glaube, die wenigsten
haben beides. Die wenigsten haben beides. Ich weiß, dass Beides geht, ja. Okay, dann
haben wir beides hier noch. Keins, beides, create. Da. Einmal please abstimmen, ob sich
das überhaupt lohnt, FFZ-Emotes zu machen. Ich weiß, dass man bei FFZ BetterTwitchTV
anzeigen lassen kann. Ich weiß allerdings nicht, ob man... Ach, BetterTwitchTV kann
auch FFZ, okay. Ja, ja, FFZ kann BetterTwitchTV-Emotes. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob BetterTwitchTV-Emotes
FFZ-Emotes kann. Ihr habt wirklich beide Twitch-Addons? Echt? Okay. Ich hab nur noch FFZ seit einem
Jahr oder so. Warum eigentlich? Also, was ist der Grund für euch beides zu haben? Interessiert
mich wirklich jetzt. Weil das einzige, was ich bei FFZ vermisse ist, dass die ne History
haben. Das alte BetterTwitchTV hatte ne History. Da hast du im Chat was geschrieben und konntest
dann mit Pfeil hoch und Pfeil runter, wie in der Linux-Commando-Zeile so ein bisschen,
deinen letzten Chat-Nachrichten durchswitchen. Hab aber keinen mit dem Option-Knopf gefunden,
Alter. Okay, also lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, wenn man sagt, wir machen auch noch 24 FFZ-Emotes.
Ich mein, wir haben ja alle BetterTwitchTV-Emotes haben wir ja schon voll. Ich könnte die ja
auch mal ein bisschen updaten wieder. Aber dann haben wir noch mal 20 Emotes zusätzlich.
So, also wir brauchen einen neuen User. Zwar nennen wir den User mal cute-chat. Display-Name
brauchen wir nix, Default, Group, alles, alles gut. Unlimited-Quota, Groups, Admin, ne.
Ich Groups Admin. Ich glaub da gehen manche auch bei Groups Admin. Passwort, 1, 2, 3,
4, 5, 6. Du brauchst keinen User, du brauchst einen Dark Mode, ja. Wisst ihr was, wir machen
alles mit Admin. Wir machen einfach alles mit Admin. Warum? Warum überhaupt? Gibt es
einen Link zu den BetterTwitchTV-Emotes von Maxi? Ich glaube es gibt einen Link, wo man
sich alle Channel-Emotes anzeigen lassen kann von einem gewissen Channel. Aber ansonsten
wüsste ich jetzt nicht. Also man sieht, du siehst, wenn du BetterTwitchTV installiert
hast, siehst du unten, wenn du auf den Smiley klickst, wo die Emotes sind, siehst du die
Emotes vom Channel. Oder sieht man das in BetterTwitchTV? Ich denke schon, bei FFZ sieht man es. Ne,
das Hint ist, es müssten 25 oder so sein, mehr gibt es nicht. Darkseam, ja, wo ist das
neue, das haben sie doch beworben, dass es jetzt ein neues Darkseam gibt. Wo schaltet
man das ein? Settings, Theming, hier. Ne. Ach ne, das ist ja auch die Admin. Das ist
ja auch die Admin-Konsole. Das kann man bestimmt für User spezifisch machen, ne. Wo ist das
neue? Wo schaltet man das Darkseam ein? Settings. Ach doch, hier, Personal Info, bla, bla, bla.
Accessibility, Darkseam, jawoll. Ach, gleich schon viel besser, oder? Viel besser. Was
haben wir zur Auswahl? Open Dill Lexic. Der Font sieht mega beschissen aus. Warum sollte
ich diesen Font dann verwenden um alles in der Welt? Der Font sieht richtig räudig aus,
warum soll ich das Ding dann verwenden? Okay, vielleicht sieht es nur unter Linux-Kacke
aus. Gucken wir mal wie das im Chrome ist. Ach, das ist, das, das bedeutet irgendwas,
oder was? Dill, Dill, Dill, Dill, Dill, Dill, Dill, Dill, Dill, Dill, Dill, Dill, Dill,
Dill, Dill, Dill. Ach so. Dann ergibt das Sinn. Was ich nicht verstehe ist, wenn man,
inwieweit hilft einem denn ein Font bei einer Leserechtschreibschwäche? Das interessiert
mich jetzt wirklich, wie inwieweit hilft mir das jetzt? Betont das gewisse Sachen so, dass
dass ich es mir einfacher merken kann, ah Reading Errors ok, interessant was es nicht
alles gibt, ich hätte jetzt nicht gedacht, dass einem eine Schriftart helfen kann, weil
diese Rechtschreibschwäche, aber man lernt ja nicht aus, ok jetzt gucken wir erstmal
was für Apps standardmäßig dabei sind mittlerweile, eine Sache die mir auch überhaupt nicht gefallen
hat war die Notizenapp, die war richtig crap, ich verwende schon seit einer ganzen Weile
diese Geschichte hier als Notizapp, so wirklich glücklich bin ich damit aber auch nicht,
wir gucken uns mal die offizielle Notizapp an wie die mittlerweile ist, Passport, oja
hoch secure Passport, Achtung Leute 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, so dann brauchen wir noch die
To Do App, ja wobei die hieß nicht To Do, die hieß Task glaube ich, Tasks download and
enable, ok was haben die eigentlich mittlerweile, wir gucken mal was es mittlerweile für Apps
alles so gibt, das sind ja wohl die im offiziellen, ah ne das sind meine, ok schauen wir mal was
gibt es denn alles so für Apps, Cup, gibt es kein Cup, manchmal verwirrt mich der Twitchchat,
jetzt ist jetzt der Partyparod am Start, Cup ist eine halbe, Cup, ich wusste gar nicht
dass es das alles im Out gibt, warum, weil er so rein sneaked, was ist das für ein
Cup, also quasi ein bisschen so hier, es sneaked auch rein, verstehe, dann machen wir
ein halbes Cup als Emote, es gibt eh noch jede Menge coole Emotes, die ich noch nicht
drin habe, ich habe zuletzt meine Emotes vor einem Jahr oder so aktualisiert, wir brauchen
unbedingt Five Head, wenn wir wieder irgendwelche Big Brain Sachen machen oder irgendwas ausversehen
löschen, wir brauchen unbedingt noch unser Five Head Emote, für die 900 IQ Kommandozahlenbefehle,
wie lange läuft deine Banner TwitchTV Subscription auf die Emotes, ich habe automatisch Verlängerungen
gemacht, 3 Head, ja den gibt es auch noch, das ist der Oi Typ ist das, oi, Monkratos,
Monkratos brauchen wir auch noch, wir sollten im Discord, im Discord kann man noch bestimmt
eine Abstimmung machen oder Vorschläge oder sowas, was wir für Emotes brauchen, da überlege
ich mir mal was, da machen wir irgendwie so eine, machen wir im Discord so eine Liste
oder irgendwie was, wo man abstimmen kann, dass ich, ich meine ich werde ein paar Emotes
rein machen, auch wenn die nicht auf der Liste drin sind, aber ein paar muss man ja gucken,
das ist immer, wäre ja blöd wenn ich vielleicht irgendwas nicht kenne, obwohl das eigentlich
ein nicees Emote ist, Pepega, Pepega müssten wir eigentlich haben, aber nicht mal Pepega
als Emote, oh das ist aber bitter, ja Siebaro kannst du, kannst du machen, wir müssen aber
noch überlegen, wie wir das mit der Abstimmung machen, äh, es geht nicht um Emotes auf
dem Discord, es geht darum, welche Emotes ich als, als, als FFZ Emotes für den Channel
nehmen kann, weil ich habe alle 25 BellaTwitchTV Emotes und ich habe noch 25 offenen FFZ Emotes,
ja und wenn ich dann mal Partner bin, dann gibt es ja auch richtige Emotes, allerdings
nicht so viele, weil es werden jetzt ja nicht gleich irgendwie riesen Anzahl an Abos geben,
aber so ein paar wird es, da muss ich mir echt mal Gedanken machen, was ich da nehme,
auf jeden Fall müssen wir noch MonkaSmoke als extra Emote einreichen, bei, bei BellaTwitchTV,
okay, ähm, wir machen jetzt mal weiter, LulWee, ja LulWee muss auch sein, ich verwende eigentlich
auf allen Channels, wo es LulWee gibt, eigentlich fast nur LulWee anstatt Lul, wer sich kennt,
LulWee ist einfach ein rangezoomtes Lul, weil Twitch, großartige Logik ist leider nicht
dahinter zu erkennen, ja, übrigens, äh, wer neu am Start ist und das auch noch nicht
mitgekriegt hat, wir haben also einen Discord Server, Ausrufezeichen Discord, wer noch nicht
gefollowed ist, kann mir gerne followen, auf Twitter und natürlich auch auf Twitch, da
seid ihr immer auf dem aktuellsten Stand, wenn der Stream live geht oder wenn es irgendwelche
anderen Sachen gibt, und jetzt haben wir Sellout-Modus beendet, jetzt machen wir weiter mit Next
Cloud, ähm, okay, was, was, was haben sie mittlerweile standardmäßig für, für Apps
dabei, App-Order, sortieren, das brauch ich nicht nur mit den Customs hier, das blablabla,
braucht man nicht, Random Background from Unsplash, das gefällt mir, ich weiß zwar
nicht genau, was wir damit machen, aber das installieren wir einfach mal, Random Background
ist immer, immer nice, äh, External Sites brauchen wir an der Stelle nicht, das brauchen
wir auch nicht, okay, was haben wir sonst noch so, Files, äh, PDF Viewer, der ist standardmäßig
dabei, Tiffties brauche ich nicht, brauche ich auch nicht, Draw IO als Addon für Next
Cloud, okay, das ist cool, das muss ich mir mal angucken, ich hab ja, wir haben ja schon
öfters hier, äh, Draw, Draw IO Bildchen gemacht, gibt es Draw IO auch als Desktop Client eigentlich,
also Desktop, in Anführungsstrichen, das ist wahrscheinlich eine Elektronen Anwendung
oder sowas, ne, aber es ist cool, wenn er das einfach auf Next Cloud speichert, das,
das gefällt mir, ähm, Camera Rob Reviews brauche ich nicht, Check Zoom, das ist nice,
das können wir auch mal aktivieren, sollte das jetzt nicht eigentlich Enable, ups, ich
hab das falsche angeklickt, Alter, jebaited, jetzt hab ich hier den Mist Enabled, den ich
gar nicht haben will, äh, wie hieß das Ding, Raw, Disable, Next Cloud Games brauche ich
wirklich nicht als Next Cloud Anwendung, Keep all the random clean your Next Cloud Data,
warum nicht, Integrations, Draw IO haben wir schon, After Logic, Webmail Client, okay,
Circles, Circles klingt mir viel zu sehr nach Google Plus, findet ihr nicht auch, da hier
zusammen Editierzeug, brauche ich auch nicht, Git, Git hat Merge Tracker, ein Keepers Client,
nein, den brauche ich auch nicht unbedingt da, Only Office, was ist denn Only Office,
Ist ein Open Source Office Paket, ist das, ist das, ähm, ist das Libre Office mit Support
oder was ist das, ach ne, das ist ein komplett anderes, das ist ein eigenständiges Office,
okay, hab ich noch nie was von gehört, aber wie gesagt ich verwende auch keine Office
Software, Markdown Editor, Edit Text Editor, Plane Text, Markdown drüber reicht für 95%
der Sachen, und ich sage es jedem Stream, die einzige Anwendung, die eine Daseinsberechtigung
hat in dem Office Paket ist meiner Ansicht nach die Tabellengalkulation, OCR, OCR ist
cool wenn es richtig funktioniert, da könnte man beispielsweise ein Foto machen von irgendeinem
Dokument oder ein eingescanntes Dokument in Nextcloud schieben und das Ding macht OCR
drauf und man kann es durchsuchen, das wäre natürlich richtig cool, wie Previews zu Markdown,
meistens gar nicht, das einzige wo ich das mal in schön brauche ist für einen Changelog
oder sowas, weil unsere Changelogs auf der Arbeit, das ist alles in, unser Haupt Changelog
quasi ist in Markdown und da habe ich, wie heißt das, Crip glaube ich, das ist so ein
Peißending oder so, das startest du einfach und das rendert dir alle Markdown Files in
einem Verzeichnis und dann kannst du das rauskopieren dann. Ansonsten hat, QR Notes hat einen
eigenen Markdown Preview drinnen, das verwende ich allerdings habe ich den Markdown Vorschau
ausgeschaltet, verwende eigentlich bloß noch das Synthax Highlighting für Markdown,
weil das das Dokument auch ein bisschen strukturiert, ansonsten stinkt normales Plain Text. Was
ist Nextcloud? Eine Cloud Lösung zum selber Hosten, wobei Cloud in dem Sinne eigentlich
ein bisschen trügerisch ist an der Stelle, es hat mit Cloud relativ wenig zu tun, weil
und der Cloud versteht mir ja gerade, dass es nicht bei dir läuft, dass du auch wenig
Einfluss hast drauf wo es läuft und wie es eigentlich genau läuft, das ist im Prinzip
stinknormale PAP Anwendung, die relativ viele nützliche Funktionen und Apps hat. Also im
Kern ist es eigentlich ein Filesynchronisierung Service sowie Dropbox, das ist so der Kern,
plus Kalender und Kontaktlisten. Also die zwei Sachen, Kalender und Filesync, das ist
eigentlich so im Kern, das wofür Nextcloud da ist. Es gibt allerdings halt noch zig andere
Apps, wir gucken uns gerade mal an, was es da jetzt Neues gibt. Wie gesagt, die letzte
Version, die ich installiert habe, war 13. OCR könnte man vielleicht mal ausprobieren,
das ist glaube ich ganz nützlich, wenn es gut funktioniert. Sentry, war Sentry nicht
so ein bisschen was wie Jenkins, nur neuer. Social Login. Ja das ist jetzt alles nicht
so das was man jetzt mal ausprobieren muss, das haben wir uns alle schon gesehen, Admin
Notification, Quota Warning, das ist ganz praktisch, weil man das mit mehreren Leuten
verwendet. Decryption, wenn man sich Loki eingefangen hat. Ein Audioplayer gibt es
mittlerweile auch, ok. Ich hatte zwar bisher noch nie das Bedürfnis in meiner Nextcloud
im Browser Audio Sachen abzuspielen, weil ich mein Audio Zeug überhaupt nicht mehr
im Lokal hab. Eines der wenigen Clouddienste übrigens, die ich verwende, also Amazon Music.
Ebook reader, Folder Player, GPX Edit, blablabla, das ist alles nicht so das was ich jetzt
unbedingt brauche. Phone Track, das wollte ich mal ausprobieren. Das wollte ich mal ausprobieren,
das hab ich schon vor ner Weile gelesen. Da kann man, also aktuell mach ich es ja so,
meine Presence Detection für Heimautomatisierung besteht ja aus mehreren Sachen, einmal ob
ich im WLAN bin, ob mein Gerät gepinkt werden kann und solche Geschichten und ich hab auf
meinem iPhone ne Tracking Software laufen, die nennt sich, wie nennt die sich nochmal?
Gute Frage, Own Tracks, genau. Das hab ich bei mir laufen auf dem iPhone und das hat
verschiedene Modi, da kannst du einstellen, wie oft das quasi lockt, wo du gerade bist
und es funktioniert halt ohne Clouddienste. Der schickt es dann an mein Heimautomatisierung
System, Heim über nen Server im Internet, verschlüsselt und dann weiß meine Heimautomatisierung
immer wo ich bin und viel wichtiger, ob ich gerade auf dem Weg Heim bin und ob es spezielle
Dinge machen soll. Ja und deswegen wollte ich mal Phone Track ausprobieren, das kann
diese Daten wohl auswerten und man kann sich dann Bewegungsprofile anzeigen lassen und
was, da seh ich dann keine Ahnung, dass ich immer beim Asia All You Can Eat Freitag sitze
und All You Can Eat Snackaria Asia mache. Radio, ich hör zwar kein Radio, aber ich will
es mal ausprobieren, wie gut das funktioniert. Ebook brauch ich nicht, Talk juckt mich überhaupt
nicht in On Cloud Office Text. Quick Notes, achso da sind irgendwelche Pappen, ne die brauch
ich nicht. Hatten die nicht auch den Markdown Reader? Notifications for calendar events.
Full Text Search, haben sie das mittlerweile geschafft? Das wäre natürlich sehr nice.
Welches davon sollen wir jetzt nehmen? Full Text Search, Full Text Search Files, Full
Text Search Elastic Plattform, Full Text Search OCR, was ist davon jetzt das Richtige? Full
Text Search Bookmarks, weiß ich nicht. Warum haben wir den Markdown Editor gerade nirgendwo
gesehen oder hab ich den einfach übersprungen? Ich würde ja, ach ist der unter Tools? Ist
der unter Tools irgendwo? Hier müsste ja A, B, C, D, E, F, G, H, J, K, L, M, Markdown,
ich seh hier kein Markdown, müsste hier irgendwo sein. Aber was auch immer, brauchen wir jetzt
eh nicht gerade. So, ach guck mal, das macht wirklich die random Hintergründe, das ist
ja witzig. Kona, ja. Mal gucken wie das Video abspielen im Browser mittlerweile klappt
hier. Achso, gut. Obwohl gemerkt, das ist alles in der VM, ne? Wir sind ja eigentlich
unter Windows und Linux in der VM. Also ich muss sagen, das Webinterface sieht im Prinzip
noch genauso aus wie unter Nextcloud 13, allerdings hat es schon ein paar sinnvolle Verbesserungen.
Erstmal ein Dark Theme, das hier hätten wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen schöner machen
können, modified, ein recent used, recent added, das ist auch ganz praktisch. Ok, probieren
wir mal. Tasks App aus. Highspeed, aber gut, das läuft auch im Raspberry. Tasks, Check,
Twitch, Chat, Spammen, Wonka, X hinzufügen. So, jetzt haben wir ein paar Tasks, die kann
man danach jetzt suchen. Kann ich suchen, oder? Kann man die Tasks suchen mittlerweile? Ah,
sie haben das in die Suche oben integriert. Das ist schon mal gut, das ging das letzte
Mal noch nicht. Das war bei Nextcloud 13, war das noch kaputt. Man konnte To Do's anlegen,
konnte die To Do's aber nicht durchsuchen, das fand ich ziemlich fail. Ach man, ok,
wir testen mal, ob man, ob der auch die zusätzlichen Sachen durchsucht. Achso. Hey! Ok, das ist
schon mal besser wie vorher. Das ist sogar mal eine, da kann man die App halbwegs gebrauchen
mittlerweile anscheinend. Completed. Gut, ich meine ich werde, ich verwende als den Webclient
hier für To Do's wahrscheinlich eh nicht oft, oder aktuell verwende ich ihn nie, aber
ich habe, ich fand es schon ein bisschen blöd, dass noch nicht mal die Suche funktioniert
hat vorher, also früher bei der alten Version. Ich meine, eine To Do Anwendung ohne Suche
ist irgendwie ziemlich sinnlos. Ach ja, wir müssten Thunderbird installieren, um die
ganzen Kalender- und To Do-Funktionen mal testen zu können. Was haben wir sonst noch
hier? Radio. Das Dark Theme ist auch nicht so ganz konsistent. Ok, ich weiß nicht, was
es jetzt hier macht, aber es macht nicht viel. Achso. Das buggt rum auf jeden Fall, wenn man
es anklickt. Ok, ich meine ich höre kein Radio, aber es sieht auf den ersten Blick
so aus, als würde es funktionieren. Stimmt, außerdem ist Dark Theme in der Beta. Ok,
Nodes, gucken wir uns mal die Notiz-Anwendung an. Leider, es gibt wirklich verdammt wenige
gute Apps für Kalender und To Do's, die nach Möglichkeit auch unter Windows funktionieren
oder unter Linux, weil Kalender findest du noch halbwegs. Software, die Call of Kalender
kann, findest du noch halbwegs. Was du eigentlich so gut wie gar nichts findest, ist Software,
die ordentlich To Do's unterstützt. Es gibt zwar, ich sag mal, Gott und die Welt hat
einen To Do Programm, allerdings können die meisten dann keine Call of To Do's, was
wieder doof ist, weil dann kann man es nicht sünken gescheit. Wobei es eigentlich dumm
ist, weil iOS kann es von Haus aus, die Standard To Do App, unter Android ist es relativ einfach
hinzuzufügen, aber so wirklich für einen Desktop gibt es kaum gescheite Call of Anwendungen.
Aber Call of ist auch ein scheiß Protokoll, muss man ehrlich sagen. Das ist so ekliges
XML-Geschwubbel, also ich will nicht sagen, dass es vom Ansatz her schlecht ist, aber vom
Protokoll an sich. Ich mein, keiner macht 2019 auch gerne XML. Oder haben wir XML?
XML-Cuties am Start. Kennst du Task Warrior? Ja, Task Warrior ist ziemlich gut. Das Problem
ist, dass Task Warrior auch nicht für alle Plattformen zur Verfügung steht. Ist Own
Cloud nicht besser? Nö. Next Cloud ist quasi Own Cloud, bloß moderner und mit den ursprünglichen
Leuten hinter Own Cloud. Task Warrior ist das Problem, dass du es nicht... Also Task Warrior
könntest du auf zwei Sachen lösen. Entweder sie würden Clients rausbringen für alle Plattformen,
dann könntest du es verwenden. Das bedeutet allerdings auch für Windows, für iOS und
für Linux, für Mac und für Android. Und ich glaube für iOS zum Beispiel gibt es keinen
ordentlichen Task Warrior Client. Oder aber sie würden Sync zu Kaldorf erlauben. Wahnsinnig.
Ok, Nodes. Ok, New Node. Ist ganz schön langsam, aber das ist auch noch Raspberry. Und man
merkt, dass das Darkseam Beta ist, weil so wirklich schön verdienen lässt sich noch
nicht. Ok, also Rhyme, Nodes. Tolle Nodes. Ach so, ah. Das ist der neue Markdown Editor
hier im... Der noch nicht mal List... Ah doch, macht er. List, macht er. Kann er Syntax
Highlight? Das ist immer... Wenn ihr mal ordentlichen Markdown Editor testen wollt, guckt ob er
Syntax Highlight kann, dann seht ihr gleich ob das Ding ordentlich ist oder nicht. Nope,
kann er nicht. Ist kein ordentlicher Markdown Editor. Kein Syntax Highlight. Für Code
Logs. Ja und... Ender Boy, wie nennt sich das? Mathjacks oder so, ne? Es gibt ja mittlerweile
für Markdown die Plugins, dass du da direkt Latex drin machen kannst, dass du da Mathjacks
drin machen kannst. Ja ich glaub so heißt das. Das ist als... Ja, das da. Dass man Formel
einfügen kann. Ja dafür hätte ich auch gerne Support. Wollen wir mal ausprobieren ob das
funktioniert? Ich denke nicht, dass es funktioniert. Brauchen wir mal ein Beispiel? Ich glaube
nicht, dass es funktioniert. Wobei, wo kann man sich jetzt das Geränder da anzeigen lassen?
Preview. Nee, kann er nicht. Kann er nicht. Aber zumindest so Basic Markdown. Aber sag
man mal so, das ist jetzt nichts tolles, weil... Warum kann man hier jetzt nicht mehr drinne
markieren? Das ist jetzt auch wirklich nichts tolles, dass sie das mittlerweile eingebaut
haben, weil so nen 0815 Textfeld mit Markdown Syntax machst du in 5 Zeilen JavaScript. Was
ist mein Lieblings Markdown Editor? Ich hab ihn ehrlich gesagt noch nicht gefunden. Mein
Lieblings Editor an sich ist eigentlich Wim, weil ich den direkt hier inline im Terminal
aufmachen kann. Allerdings ist Visual Studio Code in letzter Zeit auch schwer gestiegen
bei mir so in der Nutzungsdauer. Die Musik, ja ich weiß auch nicht was mit das da los
ist. Die wiederholt sich vor allem die ganze Zeit und ist zu laut. Ansonsten klingt die
ganz okay, aber warum sich das wiederholt, versteh ich auch nicht. Wahrscheinlich hat
der Typ bloß 30 Sekunden gemacht und die haben da draußen einen 5 Minuten Track gebastelt.
Am liebsten wär mir ja, wenn Emacs Org Mode nen ordentlichen Kaldorf Sync hätte. Hat
es aber nicht. Es hat so nen ganz ganz rudimentären Sync, der aber zum Beispiel schon daran aufhört,
dass es keine To-Do Sync hat und dass der Two-Base Sync auch nicht ordentlich funktioniert.
Das wär mir am liebsten. So jetzt müssen wir mal, ich brauch jetzt zwei Sachen, wir
müssen Thunderbird installieren, weil Thunderbird der einzige Cross-Platform Kaldorf Klein ist,
der nicht sackt und der sackt an sich schon ziemlich, doch der am wenigsten sackt. Eine
Runde Thunderbird und dann brauchen wir den Nextcloud Klein und Sync ein paar Files.
Ach nee, Server Address, okay, da, da, Nextcloud, komm her, hier weg, Server Address, next,
nicht HTTPS, HTTPS, connect to your account. Oh, die haben jetzt so einen komischen Authentifizierungswizard
hier noch am Start. Login, Admin 123456, hohes, segures Passwort. Was willst du mit Nextcloud
machen? Eigentlich hauptsächlich Files Sync bei mir daheim und ab und zu ein paar Sachen
halt vom Smartphone, meine ganzen Notizenkrams vom Smartphone Sync und Kalender, To-Do's
und Kontakte. Also eigentlich die Basics. Und das, was, Account, Grand Access. Der Button
bringt es auch richtig, wenn du sonst nichts machen kannst auf der Seite. Okay, Sync everything
from Server as Confirmable. Home Test, Nextcloud, ja, okay, passt, connect. Es synkt. Es ist
gesynkt. Nextcloud. Ah, sehr schön. Funzt. Gut, dann machen wir mal ein bisschen was größeres
rein und gucken was passiert. Wir sind jetzt mal, wir sind jetzt mal gemein, wir machen
jetzt mal Nextcloud, mal gucken wie, mal gucken wie er das handelt. Das bedeutet gar nichts,
das bedeutet ich hab mich verschrieben und mein LS-Kommando ist so schlau und checkt,
dass ich das gar nicht haben will. Welche Distribution ist das eigentlich? Das ist Manjaro,
Manjaro mit i3 als Desktop. Okay, gucken wir mal wie das den DD handelt. Ich mein, dafür
ist es nicht gedacht, aber wir können es ja mal ausbringen. Von Def Random, wir machen
mal nicht nullen, wir machen random. Von Def Random nach blob.dxd, blob.bin, die Änderung
ist ja, wie gesagt, das ist eigentlich egal. Blocksize 1M, count, machen wir mal 10, wir
machen mal eine 10mb-Datei. Def Random ist übelst lahm, ne? Stimmt. Was war, u-random
war glaub ich schneller, gell? Urandom, jawoll. So, und jetzt synkt das jetzt? Noch hat's
nicht gesynkt, ne? Hat es schon gesynkt? Hat schon gesynkt. Oh, das hat er aber schnell
kapiert. RM. Ah, okay, das geht schneller als bei 13 noch. Bei 13 hat das eine ganze
Ecke gedauert oftmals. Was ist daran besser als Google Drive oder Dropbox? Nix. Also von
der Funktion her nicht wirklich nix. Es kann mehr, aber von der Funktion her, vom
Filesync her, also ich würde sagen, dass der reine Sync von Dropbox wahrscheinlich
besser ist. Zumindest hatte ich in der Vergangenheit mit dem Sync Probleme von Nextcloud. Aber
wenn es dich nicht stört, deine Daten woanders liegen zu haben als bei dir, dann kannst du
natürlich auch Dropbox nehmen. Also wenn man keine Abneigung gegen Cloud-Software hat,
dann braucht man das auch nicht. Das ist nur für Leute, die die Sache bei sich lokal
laufen lassen wollen. Und ich will halt mein Zeug nicht bei Dropbox oder bei Google Drive
oder bei Amazon Drive oder was da so noch alles gibt lagern. Es gibt eine ganz gute Zwischenlösung,
wenn man sagt, hey, man möchte nicht sein eigenes Filesync-Ding betreiben. Ich meine,
da gehört ja auch noch ein bisschen was für Aluhutler, genau. Da gehört ja noch ein bisschen
mehr dazu. Wenn du wirklich das so betreiben möchtest, dass du es nutzen kannst ein bisschen
wie Dropbox, dann musst du dir auch dafür sorgen, dass das extern erreichbar ist. Und
extern erreichbar in einem privaten Service ist immer doof, was dann wiederum heißt,
du brauchst wahrscheinlich einen VPN. Das ist schön und sicher funktioniert und ganz
gut. Da gehört dann ein bisschen mehr dazu. Wie greifst du jetzt von außerhalb drauf
zu? Gar nicht. Ich mache das ganz primitiv. Ich trage einfach Sachen bei mir ein oder
ich mache Notizen bei mir auf dem Tablet oder so. Und sobald das Tablet bei mir daheim
ins WLAN geht, dann synkt es das. Das reicht aber auch. Genau, es gibt auch eine ganz gute
Zwischenlösung. Wenn man Google Drive oder Dropbox verwenden will, dann kann man einfach
das verschlüsselt machen. Allerdings sollte man darauf achten, dass das ein Verfahren
ist, was dann eine jeweilige mobile Client auch unterstützt. Wenn man nur Linux-Systeme
hat, kann man einfach NKFS oder so etwas verwenden. Oder was? E-Crypt-FS. Ich habe
schon ewig nicht mehr verwendet. Der verschlüsselt auf Dateiebene. Und das ist wichtig, wenn
man sowas wie Google Drive verschlüsselt verwenden will, dann muss man auf Dateiebene
verschlüsseln, nicht auf Device-Ebene. Also auf Device-Ebene sieht das Dropbox und
Google Drive gar nicht. Und du kannst auch nicht einfach einen True-Crypt oder einen
Vera-Crypt-Container nehmen und auf dein Dropbox-Laufwerk legen, weil dann denkt Dropbox, dass bei
jeder Änderung sich die gesamte Datei geändert hat. Das macht das Ding kaputt. Das funktioniert
nicht. Das heißt, man muss irgendetwas nehmen, was auf Dateiebene verschlüsselt. Ja, und
man braucht halt Clients, die es wieder entschlüsseln können. Was ist denn mit der Musik los? Die
ist wirklich kacke. Concentrate your Asian... Ah, nee, nee. Kein Hip-Hop Zeug. A relaxing
study. Procursive Housemix, was sagt der Zeug gibt? Oh, nee. Ich sag eigentlich überhaupt
nicht meine Musikrichtung, aber im Hintergrund kann ich mir jetzt kein Heavy-Metal-Gehemmere
anhören oder sowas. Auch wenn es mir besser gefällt für Stream-Hintergrund, vor allem
wenn man sich ein bisschen konzentrieren muss, ist das nichts. So, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Genau, wir wollten gucken, ob der ganze Kram synkt. Können wir nochmal testen. Also, drauf
die Ideen funktioniert wunderbar und schnell. Gucken wir mal, was er macht, wenn man das
ein bisschen hintereinander spammt. Wahrscheinlich nix, wahrscheinlich synkt er einfach das Neueste.
Ja, was passiert, wenn wir die gleiche Datei... Ah, das synkt er neu. Haha. Was natürlich
auch nicht ganz optimal ist, wenn er die gleiche Datei mit dem gleichen Inhalt doppelt synkt.
Egal, aber der Synk wirkt jetzt schon deutlich stabiler als das letzte Mal. Das letzte Mal
hat er hier teilweise irgendwie eine Minute rumgewurstet, bis er überhaupt angefangen
hat zu synken. Milch ist auch Gift, ja. Milch ist vor allem mittlerweile ein Symbol... Oh,
ne, was haben sie erzählt? Ein Symbol weißer, männlicher Weltanschauung, ja. Milch. Mittlerweile
nimmt das alles Ausmaße an, da denkst du dir, was geht mit denen ab. Und ihr wisst ja auch,
das Wort Woman oder Women ist auch ganz furchtbar sexistisch, ja. Weil da kommt das Wort, da
kommt in Woman, kommt Mann drin vor. Und das ist böse. Das ist ganz böse. Deswegen sagt
man jetzt, wenn man quasi nicht anecken will bei Feministen, muss man sagen Woman. Klingt
zwar übel, als könnte man nicht richtig sprechen, aber so ist das heutzutage. Woman. Also irgendwie
sind sie... Irgendwie die Welt ist teilweise schon nicht mehr ganz dicht, ist das anbelangt.
Okay, ähm, tja, wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Weiter. Also, SYNK sieht erstmal okay aus.
Wir können... Wir müssen jetzt eigentlich mal probieren, mal 5000 Files zu synken. Ich
zeige euch jetzt nochmal was. Ähm, oder machen wir mal, machen wir mal Fangfrage. Was ist
die einfachste Variante, 1000 Files zu erstellen? Jetzt hier auf der Shell unter Linux in diesem
Verzeichnis. Dateien sollen heißen 1 bis 1000. Ah, Q-Chat fragen. Also ich, ich weiß, wie
es geht, aber vielleicht, was habt ihr da so für Ideen? Dateien erstellen 1000 Stück,
1 bis 1000 soll der Dateiname sein, möglichst kurz und knackig jetzt hier auf der Shell.
Wie würdet ihr es machen? Irgendeine Vorlobe in der Bash, das geht noch einfacher, aber
das ist schon mal ein guter Ansatz. Vorlobe in der Bash ist auf jeden Fall nicht verkehrt.
Touch 1, Touch 1 ist schon mal gut. Ah ne, Touch 1, 2 ist, äh, das ist zu langsam. Man
kann sowas hier machen. Touch, 1 bis 1000. Und bam, hat man 1000 Files. Mal gucken, was
das Ding da jetzt macht. Ohje. Jetzt, jetzt haben wir es. Jetzt haben wir es geschafft.
Wow. Wo kommt die Auslastung her? Das sind 0-byte-Dateien. Warum verursachen, warum verursachen
1000 Dateien mit 0-byte so eine krasse Auslastung? Na gut, ist logisch eigentlich, die muss neu
angelegt werden. Das heißt, es müssen neue Metadaten gespeichert werden in der SQLite-Datenbank
von Nextcloud. Aber es wirkt mir doch ein bisschen ziemlich CPU-intensiv für 1000 leere
Dateien. Und wir sind wohlgemerkt, wir sind auf der SSD, ne? Wir sind auf der SSD. Also,
wir sind jetzt nicht irgendwie auf der langsamen MicroSD-Karte, sondern auf der SSD. Ja, für
Mephisto Boy ganz bestimmt, ganz bestimmt. Das kennen die meisten wahrscheinlich schon,
oder? Was der Mephisto Boy hier gepostet hat. Das da. Ich mache mal sicherheitshalber einen
Comment davor. Kennt ihr das, was das macht? Weil es gibt ein paar Seiten, wo die Leute
lustig sind und sowas als Antworten posten. Das wird euer System nicht killen, aber das
wird dafür sorgen, dass sich euer System aufhängt bis zu einem Reboot. Und zwar macht es das
folgendermaßen. Es ist ein bisschen schwierig zu erkennen, aber das ist eine Funktion in
Bash. Funktionsname ist Doppelpunkt. Das ist Funktionsdefinition. Das hier ist Body von
der Funktion. Und hier in der Stelle nichts anderes macht, wie sich selbst aufzurufen
und sich selbst noch mal im Hintergrund zu starten. Danach wird das beendet als Befehl,
dass ich auf die gleiche Zeile was Neues schreiben kann. Und jetzt rufe ich das zum ersten Mal
auf. Das heißt, hier wird es zum ersten Mal aufgerufen. Es verdoppelt sich. Ruft sich
wieder selbst auf, verdoppelt sich, verdoppelt sich das. Das ist eine Frogbomb. Wenn man
das ausführt, kackt euer System ab. Einfach weil RAM und alles so rekrutiert. Ja, im Endeffekt
schon. Es forgt sich halt zu Tode. Hab ich auch gelesen, Sebaro. Oh, er ist fertig.
So, wenn ich jetzt refresche, habe ich hier jetzt 1000 Dateien drinnen. Ägitt, Endless
Scroll. Endless Scroll. Weiche. Endless Scroll. Please. Kein Endless Scroll. Tut mir das nicht
leid. Macht Pages. Kein Endless Scroll. Kann man das umstellen? Doch, ich möchte Pages
haben. Ich mag kein Endless Scroll. Guckt euch die YouTube-Comments an, wie beschissen
das mit Endless Scroll ist. Du findest überhaupt nichts mehr richtig. Wenn ich jetzt ein Video
habe mit 1000 Comments und ich bin halt jemand, der liest alle Comments unter seinen Videos,
und ich weiß auch, da hat mal einer was gepostet. Das war relativ am Anfang vom Video. Ich finde
den Scheiß nicht mehr. Doch, bei Dateien auch. Mag das nicht. Guck mal, es ist doch total
beknackt. Warum muss ich jetzt, mal angenommen, ich will jetzt Datei, wenn wir mal ausblenden,
dass es eine Suche gibt. Ich weiß, ich will Datei 500 haben. Warum muss ich dann Endless
Scroll machen, bis 500? Warum kann ich nicht einfach auf Seite 8 gehen, oder sowas? Und
übrigens, ein Dateibrowser macht das auch nicht so. Ein Dateibrowser macht das, ach
nee, warum habe ich jetzt gefräscht. Ein Dateibrowser zeigt dir einfach alle Dateien
auf einmal an, und Endless Scroll nicht. Ich habe ja nicht das Problem, dass das alle Dateien
auf einer Seite hat. Ich habe das Problem, dass nicht alle Dateien da standardmäßig
drin stehen. Ich mag kein Endless Scroll. Auf Reddit ist das auch die Pest Endless Scroll.
Und auf Reddit Mobile sagen sie immer noch, ja installier dir doch die App, dann hast
du Endless Scroll. Das ist für mich ein weiterer Grund zu sagen, nee, Reddit, ich installiere
bestimmt keine Reddit App, weil ich will gerade kein Endless Scroll haben. Ich mag
kein Endless Scroll, und zumindest sollte es optional sein. Oder umgedreht, wenn man
schon sagt Default Endless Scroll, könnte man ja halt hier oben irgendwas machen mit
Endless Scroll ausschalten. LazyLoady macht aber schon den Fall zu Millionen von Adayas,
das ist korrekt, allerdings hätte ich Millionen Dateien nicht in einem Ordner.
How to disable Infinite Scroll? Gar nicht anscheinend. Was für eine Distro, das ist
mancharo mit i3-WM. Ja anscheinend geht das nicht zu disablen. Ich meine, das ist jetzt
kein KO Kriterium, ich mag Endless Scroll, aber einfach nicht. Das fängt schon damit
an, wenn ich jetzt hier irgendwas tracken und droppen will, da muss ich dann hier so
komisch rumwursten, bis das geladen ist, also es ist nicht schön. Also mir gefällt's nicht.
Ich kann verstehen, wenn man sagt, das ist Geschmackssache, mir kann aber keiner erzählen
so nach dem Motto, Endless Scroll ist beste. Es bleibt Geschmackssache. Und mir gefällt
Endless Scroll nicht. Wie die sich auf Twitter aufgeregt haben, wo ich mein Zenf zum Call
of Duty 2, was es 2-Modus gegeben hab. Da waren ja paar richtig angepisste Call of Duty
3-Modus wieder dabei diesmal. Wie markiert man denn jetzt hier alle? Geht das? Kann man
sowas machen, wie markieren von hier bis Ende, Select File Range. Guckt euch das mal an,
das ist doch nicht normal. Endless Scroll. Bleibt mir ja gar nichts anderes übrig. Und
jetzt sagen wir Delete. Und nun kriegt er das mit. Weil jetzt könnten wir einen Konflikt
verursachen. Das ist huge langsam. Gut, das liegt aber am Raspberry, das geht vor
anderem, da wär das schneller gegangen. Der brauche beim Löschen noch mehr CPU-Last von
1000 leeren Dateien, als beim Anlegen von 1000 leeren Dateien. Der Chat gerade. Ich kann
nicht oben einen Haken setzen, weil die Dateien, die will ich ja behalten. Ich wollte ja wirklich
nur Dateien von 1 bis 1000 haben. Geht RM 1 bis 1000? Klar geht das. Ich wollte es ja
übers Webinterface löschen, weil das mit RM funktioniert ist klar. Ich wollte mir angucken,
wie das funktioniert übers Webinterface. Ah, ok, der Sync alle paar Sekunden anscheinend
neu. Ok, jetzt. Das geht. Also ich muss sagen, der Sync macht einen ganz soliden Eindruck.
Auf jeden Fall besser als bei Nextcloud 13 noch. Es könnte ein bisschen schneller sein,
ja. Letztendlich legen wir 1000 leere Dateien an und löschen 1000 leere Dateien. Es könnte
ein bisschen schneller gehen, aber das schiebe ich jetzt einfach mal darauf, dass das nicht
für Massen an Dateien anlegen und löschen gerade optimiert ist und dass es auf einem
Raspberry läuft und dass es mit SQLite läuft. Wobei SQLite performance-mäßig gar nicht
übel ist als Single-User. Mit mehr Anfangs wird es schwierig. Ja, genau, der Typ. Ganz
ehrlich, dann geh Battle Spiel spielen, wenn es dir nicht gefällt. Da hatten wir auch
ein paar in den Comments drunter. Da hatten wir wieder einen Typ in den Comments, der hat
ein übelst dämliches Kommentar gepostet und auch gleich rumgeflamet. Da hab ich dann drauf
geantwortet, ey, du Dummschwerzer, blablabla. Also sein Comment war schon komplett unter
aller Kanone. Ich hab einfach nur drauf geantwortet, ey, du Dummschwerzer, dann erzähl mir mal,
was hat dir denn an den Modus gefallen? Irgendwie sowas. Und da hat er gesagt, ja, da geh ich
jetzt gar nicht drauf ein. Wahrscheinlich, weil dir nichts einfällt. Da hast du schon
immer Spezialisten teilweise am Start. Patrick, De-Abo macht man heute nicht mehr. Heute macht
man, das müssen wir mit dem passenden Nachdruck, heute macht man kein De-Abo, heute macht man
Dis-Abo, macht man heute. KappaPride Dis-Abo. Ja, PavelimomentKot bekommt eine 2x2 Modus,
der sah aber sowas von schlecht aus, dass ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass den jemand
spielt bei Release. Maps einfach nur viereckig, quadratisch viereckig, spawn direkt gegenüber
mit zwei Leuten, in der Mitte eine Kiste und es war's. So sehen alle Maps aus. Wie
heißt der RGB Text? LOLCat. LOLCat. Und das Beste ist, dadurch ihnen ist selbst aufgefallen,
dass ihre Spawns kacke sind, weil das erste, könnt ihr euch daran erinnern, das erste,
was ich gesagt hab im Stream, als ich den Modus gesehen hab, einer flasht, einer wirft
Granate. Instant, instant win. Auf die Idee sind die Entwickler von Call of Duty allerdings
auch gekommen. Man kann ja nicht sagen, die sind schon clever. Deswegen haben sie nicht
gesagt etwa, ah ok, man kann quasi aus dem Spawn heraus instant gewinnen, wir ändern
die Maps und die Spawns, nein, die sind viel schlauer. Die haben gesagt, wir deaktivieren
einfach Equipment und Granaten die ersten drei Sekunden, dann kann das nicht passieren.
Das ist mal, das ist 900 IQ. Nicht die Maps verbessern, nicht die Spawns verbessern, nein,
einfach die Granaten deaktivieren. Die sind einfach richtig re-smart, sind die. Fivehead
brauchen wir jetzt. Moment, den müssen wir jetzt hinzufügen, den brauch ich als Emote.
Fivehead Emote. Das ist für die besonders big brain Leute. Fivehead. Ja, perfekt.
Richtig, warum machen die in CS überhaupt Map Balance? Die sollen einfach Granaten deaktivieren.
Das ist die Call of Duty Logik. Dann haben die Leute geschrieben, Max, jetzt mach doch
nicht das ganze Game schlecht, nur weil der Modus nicht gut war. Wo ich mir dann immer
denke, wie kommen die Leute drauf? Das Comment, was ich geschrieben hab, hat sich exakt auf
diesen Modus bezogen und sonst nix. Außerdem ist es bei Call of Duty ja nicht so, dass
man Call of Duty noch irgendwie schlecht machen müsste. Da haben sie ja die letzten Jahre
selbst schon für gesorgt. Mittlerweile ist es eigentlich eher umgedreht. Sie müssen beweisen,
dass es wieder was taugt. Magst du alle Hater? Ja, so sieht es aus. Du kannst aber auch gar
nichts mehr heutzutage sagen, dass nicht sofort jemand super krass offended ist. Die Call
of Duty Fans waren da schon immer gut dabei. So, das Gesinke hat schön funktioniert. Muss
ich sagen, gefällt mir deutlich besser als Nextcloud 13. Dann testen wir jetzt mal, wie
Kalender und was ist eigentlich, ach so Plugpunkt Bind, das ist das, was ich vorhin angelegt
hab. Das löschen wir jetzt mal. Ja, entweder du bist Fan oder Hater, dazwischen gibt es
nix mehr. Das finde ich auch ein bisschen bitter ehrlich gesagt, weil, hab ich auch
schon mal vor Ewigkeiten im Video gesagt, eigentlich sind die Leute, die Games oder
die wie Hater aussehen, sind oftmals die größten Fans dieses Games. Allerdings nicht
so diese, ich finde alles geil Fans oder ich verteidige den Hersteller auch wenn er Scheiße
baut, sondern Fans, die das Game wegen dem Game an sich spielen. Nicht weil sie den Hersteller
unglaublich fanboyen wollen, sondern die sich eigentlich nichts mehr wünschen als
dass das Game was taugt. Und das sind halt auch Leute, die über Jahre hinweg, guckt
euch mal an, wie viele Leute WoW abonniert haben seit Release. Und ein Großteil davon
sind mittlerweile die größten Kritiker von WoW selbst. Einfach weil sie das alles mitgekriegt
haben und sagen, hey, das Spiel entwickelt sich in Richtung, die wir nicht mögen. Das
sind aber keine Hater, die einfach nur Hate verbreiten wollen, die wünschen sich eigentlich
nichts mehr als dass ihnen das Spiel wieder gefällt. Oder dass sich das Spiel, die wünschen
sich nichts mehr als dass sich das Game in die Richtung entwickelt, wie sie es gerne
hätten. Was passiert wenn zwei Clients die gleiche Datei offline editieren und das dann
gesunken versuchen? Nein, dann gibt es den Konflikt. Da spackts rum. Wobei ich mir gar
nicht mehr sicher bin, ob man nicht auch einstellen konnte, dass der letzte gewinnt. Ich glaube,
das geht auch. Ich glaube, man konnte auch einstellen, der letzte gewinnt. Auf den
Private WoW Classic Server. Gibt es nicht bald einen WoW Classic Server? Kommt doch
im August. Oder? Ist ja nicht mal lange. Doch bald. Also ich werde es auf jeden Fall spielen,
allerdings wahrscheinlich nicht super intensiv und auch nicht on stream. Einfach, dass ich
mit dem Fabian mal ein bisschen was habe, wo man wieder spielen kann. Falls der dann
spielt. Oder ein bisschen mit dem Eaxe rumrennen oder so. Das ist auch kein Spiel für streamen.
MMOs taugen zum streamen nichts. Außer man ist eine ganz passende Persönlichkeit dafür
und hat auch das passende Publikum und die passende Reichweite. Ich finde es übelst
langweilig. Ich persönlich gucke es mir nicht an. Ok, dann starten wir mal Thunderbird
und gucken, wie das mit dem Kalender-Sync ist. Was ist der Kalender überhaupt? Muss
ich das erst noch als App aktivieren? Ah ja. Download and Enable. 123456. Super Secret
Passport. Ist dann ChinaCarm angekommen? Ne, immer noch nicht. Ich hoffe mal. Ich hoffe
mal morgen. DHL, AliExpress, der 50er Pack USB Kabel. Die schreiben ja 8-17 Tage Versand
mit DHL. Und 8 Tage sind auf jeden Fall schon rum. Ne, sind nur 50 Kabel die ich bestellt
habe. Der Typ hat in der Mail irgendwie Mist geschrieben. Und ganz ehrlich, wenn mir die
Chinesen 200 Kabel schicken für den Preis von 50 ist ok. Dann lege ich einfach 150
auf den Dachboden und gut ist. Danke für den Follow. ReedyGermany. USB Kabel. Also
sollten die mir, ohne Mist, sollten die mir wirklich 200 USB Kabel statt 50 Kabel ausversehen
geschickt haben. Dann machen wir ein USB Kabel Giveaway. Allerdings müssen wir dann gucken
wie wir das machen, weil, wie der Patrick gesagt hat, die Versandkosten lohnen sich
halt nicht so. Wollte schon noch flitter raushauen, jemand nutzt dein Logo? Ne. Es gibt tatsächlich
Leute die mein Logo benutzen. Wenn man Google Bilder Search macht mit meinem Keks, findest
du wirklich Leute die irgendwann mein Logo drauf haben. Ich mein, so what, gibt's für
jeden der ein bisschen größeren Channel hat. Ok, Kalender. Wo ist der Kalender? Wo ist
der Kalender? Ach da. Der Kalender sieht mit Darktheme irgendwie ein bisschen unfertig
aus. Ok, machen wir mal einen Tests. Ok, Name ist QChat. So und in dem Kalender fügen wir
jetzt mal einen Termin ein und zwar morgen von 12 bis 14 Uhr. Jetzt haben wir morgen
für den Event rumstellen. Und Dienstag haben wir einen All-Day-Event. Arbeiten. FeelsBatman.
Create. Ach ja und morgen, stimmt, morgen haben wir noch ein Event. Stream. Ok. Ok,
der Kalender ist immer noch Mist, man kann nix, oder kann man? Day? Kann man, kann man
nicht? Hallo? Ah. Man sieht hier ist das Darktheme, das funktioniert noch nicht richtig. Ok,
zack. Save. Weil macht er wahrscheinlich automatisch. Und jetzt adde ich das mal in Thunderbird
und gucke ob das Gescheit funktioniert. Wie sieht das Lighttheme aus? Achtung Leute Sonnenbrille
aufsetzen. Ja, Hydrogen Yoyo, das ist auch ziemlich ja crap, die Online Kalenderverwaltung.
Und nachdem es ja kaum gescheite Cross-Platform Clients gibt, nehmen wir jetzt mal einen der
halbwegs funktioniert, nämlich Thunderbird. Thunderbird hier standardmäßig Darktheme,
das kann man viel besser. Nein, ich will keinen Mail-Account absetten. Ihh, was ist das für
was? Ihh. Das sieht, das sieht noch nicht mal aus wie Windhouse 95. Das sieht aus wie
Windhouse 95, das gerne, nicht Windhouse 95, das sieht hässlich aus. Das liegt aber wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen an meinem, wir probieren mal was. Man kann bestimmt GTK, man kann bestimmt
sagen man will das mit einem, mit einem anderen Theme starten. Thunderbird. Ah, ok, ich glaube
jetzt sieht es zumindest, jetzt sieht es zumindest besser aus. Es ist zwar, ähm, brauchen wir
doch die Sonnenbrille, aber es sieht jetzt wenigstens halbwegs ok aus. Oh, wo ist die
Sidebar hin? Ach da. Ok, Kalender. On Network, wir löschen den jetzt erstmal hier. Kann
man nicht löschen, weil das der einzige ist, keine Ahnung. New Kalender, On Network, Next,
Location. Ok, wie kann ich den Kalender von Next Cloud jetzt adden? Das ging doch so irgendwie.
Next. Nickname, ja, Cute Chat heißt der Kalender. Ich muss, ich muss mich doch noch anmelden
irgendwie. Ah ja, jetzt atmen. Ok. Oder auch nicht. Cute Chat ist kaputt. Dann machen wir
das schon mal so nicht. Cute Chat. Kann man sich hier den Kalender anzeigen lassen? So,
wie kriege ich, wie kriege ich mein Next Cloud Kalender in Thunderbird? Ich mein, ich könnte
nachgucken. Ich könnte nachgucken, aber so schwer kann das noch gar nicht sein. ECS ist
das Kalender-Format unten drunter. Kennst du MindTimeAI? Nö. Kann er CalDAF? Kann er
To Do's? Ok, den gibt es schon mal von Linux, das ist gut. Kann der To Do's? Das ist das
wichtige da dran. Wir könnten das mal ausprobieren. Aber erstmal müssen wir das irgendwie in Thunderbird
geedit kriegen. On Network. Ok, du hast recht, man muss CalDAF auswählen. Eigentlich ist
ECS unten drunter das gleiche. Location. Next. Cute Chat. Ah, Cute Chat ist da. Aber
Cute Chat synchronisiert nicht. Warum, dieses Gefrickel immer. Warum kann das nicht einfach
sinken? Ok, Google Time. Ja, ich schaue mir Sonntag an, das ist klar, aber da sagt er
hier schon, dass er nicht funktioniert. Und selbst wenn ich jetzt auf morgen switche ist
nichts drin. Weil Cute Chat nicht sinken kann. Crap. Ok, wir machen mal was anderes. Es gibt
glaube ich ein neues Plugin, was das viel, viel einfacher macht. Hab ich letztens irgendwo
gesehen. Also der Thunderbird Interface wird immer ekliger. Wo konnte man sich jetzt nochmal
die Plugins anzeichen lassen? Das ging doch hier rechts irgendwo. Ok, machen wir es eben
so. Wo wo sind die Addons da? Thunderbird Sync Sync Manager. Ok, ok, ok, ok, ok, ok,
ok. Wo können wir uns jetzt zwischen Nextcloud und Thunderbird? Ja genau, das brauchen wir
doch. Mein Gott ist das kompliziert wieder so einen einfachen Kalender in Thunderbird
zu adden. Hoi hoi hoi hoi hoi. TP Sync Account Manager. Dann machen wir das damit. Viel besser.
Das Addon habe ich auch letztens irgendwo gesehen. TP Sync. Da ist es fast leicht an
einen Kalender zu programmieren. Ja. Hat er das jetzt gemacht? Hat er gemacht. Er zeigt
es mir an. Ok und wo findet man das jetzt unter TB Sync Manager? Sag mal hat Thunderbird
nicht normalerweise. Ach da ist der Knopf. Wer hat sich das denn ausgedacht den Knopf
da hinzumachen? Da guckt doch kein Mensch hin. TB Sync. Add Account, Add New Account,
Kalender auf Karte auf Account. GMX. Megalull. Account Name. Ach ok jetzt muss ich auch gar
nicht den Mist reinschreiben, sondern kann einfach sagen ich will mein Nextcloud Server
sein. Account Name. Admin. Server Ull. Deader. Username. Admin. Passport. 123456. Ok. Gut.
Das ist Gefrickel ey. Wo ist das Problem? Ach Moment da muss ich jetzt nicht den Server
dann muss ich jetzt wirklich den Mist von da unten reinschreiben. Ok. The fuck? Wo ist
denn jetzt das Problem wieder ey? Admin 123456. Das ist mir jetzt echt zu doof ey. Not allowed.
Es schreckt. Not allowed. Service an der Welpe. Ja. Sehr schön. Toll. Wie gut das funktioniert.
Ich hab das ja schonmal eingerichtet, da hab ich es nicht so problematisch. Moment was
ist das für eine Ull? Es ist schön dass du es konfirmst, was muss ich neintragen?
Verraten sie eigentlich. Ok. Wir machen was anderes wir sagen. Manual Configuration. Account
Name. Admin. Server Address. Das da. Username. Admin. Passport. Finish. Service unavailable.
Oh mann. Was hat er für Schmerzen? Man weiß es nicht. Man weiß es nicht. Tja. Dann war
es das mit Thunderbird. Funktioniert das wohl nicht? Also es funktioniert schon irgendwie
wahrscheinlich aber wie auch immer. Also ich bilde mir ein. Ich müsste mal bei meinem
An- Ich kann jetzt leider schon mal HTTPS getestet. Nee kann ich nicht testen. Hab
ich nicht an. Habe ich auch kein Zertifikat für. Vor allem schon mal gar kein gültiges
Zertifikat. Ähm. Ich kann jetzt leider nicht umloggen. Auf dem anderen Account gucken
wie ich es eingerichtet habe. Ich hätte eigentlich gedacht. Dass es ziemlich einfach ist. Dass
ich einfach nach Kall darf. Nach Location. Vielleicht muss ich jetzt hier eingeben Q-Chat
oder so. Wow. Dann nehmen wir, dann nehmen wir mal das hier. Wir nehmen mal das hier.
Offline-Support brauchen wir nicht. Q-Chat. Admin. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Jaja. Safe. Ah. Ah.
Gott. Dieses rumgefrickelt. Das ist eines der Gründe wo wir es gestern von hatten.
Dass das garantiert keine normalen User mit normaler Software irgendwie dazu bewegen wird
irgendwie umzusteigen oder sowas. Ich mein. Wo ist das Problem? Einen beschissenen Kalender
hinzufügen. Ich kann jetzt auch nicht mal sagen an wem es liegt. Wahrscheinlich wird
es zur Hälfte an Thunderbird und zur Hälfte an Nextcloud liegen, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Aber es ist erbärmlich dass es nicht klappt. Jetzt schreckt. Probieren wir mal dieses komische
Thunderbird Sync-Ding. Count. I love things. Man. Er schreibt doch sogar. Works with most
on cloud Nextcloud. Admin. Cool. Nehmen wir jetzt mal die andere. Nehmen wir jetzt mal
die da. Username. Admin. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Ist ja nicht so dass es großartig kompliziert
wäre. Damn. Service unavailable. Warum auch immer. Weil. Response. Response leer. Jawoll.
Sehr gut. Ok. Nice. Vielleicht sollten wir lieber mal Google bemühen anstatt hier weiter
um zu basteln. Probieren wir es nochmal so. Nope. Ok. Thunderbird. Add. Nextcloud. Kalender.
Jetzt. Aha. Mal 16. Ok. Sollte das funktionen habe ich nichts gesagt. Sie haben es wenigstens
offiziell in ihre Seite reingeschrieben. Once you have installed. Ich will kein Address
vor ich will Kalender. Network. Wollte mich verarschen. Was das für eine beknackte Anleitung.
Ok. Ah hier. Ja das ist doch das was wir verwenden. Das ist genau das was ich die ganze Zeit schon
mache. Das da. On network. Kalender auswählen. Und location. Das ist genau das was ich die
ganze Zeit schon mache. Ich habe noch eine Idee Leute. Ich habe noch eine Idee. Ich habe
noch eine. Eine Idee habe ich noch. Network. Kalender. Location. Nein das ist im Prinzip
genau das was er hier schreibt. So und jetzt. Machen wir. Wir tragen keine Name ein. Ach
das geht gar nicht. Test. Aha. Wer hat das gedacht. Es geht nicht. Ich weiß dass es prinzipiell
funktioniert. Weil ich habe das bei mir auf dem anderen Account eingerichtet. Kann doch
nicht sein. Die verbreitetste Kalender Lösung die es quasi zum selbst hosten gibt. Und Thunderbird
eines der verbreitesten Mail Clients. Den es so gibt. Auch ohne HTTPS. Ich habe. Ich habe
ja keine HTTPS an. Das muss ohne. Ach so. Ne tatsächlich. Meine andere NetCloud Instanz
läuft auf. Hat ein gültiges Zertifikat. Allerdings. Ist die Fehlermeldung dafür ganz schön beknackt
sollte es wirklich am Zertifikat liegen. Die Url stimmt bestimmt. Irgendwas hier bestimmt.
Ach Moment. Ich habe euch mit das nehme ich. Moment. Was ist denn das für eine Url. Das
ist eine andere Url. Wo kriegt man die dann her. Moment. Ah. Da wäre ich ja nie drauf
gekommen. Da wäre ich ja nie drauf gekommen. Jetzt funktioniert das bestimmt auch mit dem
Addon. Wartet mal. Das geht jetzt bestimmt. Addons. Alter die Bedienung. Gehen wir mal
mit Discovery Service. Probieren wir nochmal. Ach ne. Admin. Das funktioniert immer noch
nicht. Manual. Admin. Admin. Unavailable. Kalenders. Ah Moment. Wir probieren nochmal
was anderes. Mein Gott ist das eingefunnelt. Discovery. Wir sagen jetzt Admin. Das da und
da machen wir Admin und QtChat hinten weg und nehmen es einfach mal so. Das Addon suckte.
Ja das muss ohne Addon gehen. Weil das Addon habe ich auf meinem anderen Rechner auch nicht
drauf. New Calender. Location. Da machen wir jetzt einfach das da rein. Next. QtChat. Easy.
Funktioniert. Funktioniert. Ok man muss einfach. Dann ist es gar nicht so kacke wie ich jetzt
getan habe die ganze Zeit. Man muss einfach nur das finden. Ja. Wenn man das weiß ist
kein Problem dann gehts eigentlich. Jetzt müsste ich die To Do's eigentlich auch drinne haben.
Hat es meine To Do's nicht gesüngt? Ich müsste eigentlich drei To Do's haben. Ich müsste
als To Do haben. Die Sachen müsste ich eigentlich als Task haben. Ok. Test. Task. Jetzt Sync.
Nervosit.
Ah, ach so, ok, das ist ein anderer Kalender, das ist ein anderer Kalender, ja ok, kann
man die, kann man die rüberschieben? Ne, na das geht natürlich nicht, das wäre zu,
zu pro. Ok, aber dann funktioniert's, das ist, warum kann man da nichts reinschreiben?
Geht. Bäh. Ah, trotzdem so schön ist die Bedienung nicht. Aber es fun- es funktioniert
halbwegs, ist halbwegs. Ok, ah, gut, ahm, ein bisschen hakelig ist das Ganze schon.
Und man merkt, dass der Raspberry halt nicht der schnellste ist.
Ja, also ich muss sagen, mir gefällt die neue Version viel besser als 13. Wenn man
weiß, wenn man weiß, wie das mit den Links funktioniert, wie man die Kalender Links kriegt,
das ist an sich auch relativ einfach zu adden. Wir könnten den Kalender mal ausprobieren.
Probier, wir probieren den Kalender mal aus. Gucken, wie der ist. Hab ich noch nicht getestet.
Wichtig ist halt, dass er To Do's unterstützt. Wie heißt der Minetime? Ne, wir laden uns
den mal hier runter. Was, E-Mail verifizieren? Ernsthaft? Das muss ich mir angucken und einmal
eine Runde roffeln. Lullen muss man. App Image runterladen. Wie geht. Probier ich jetzt
mal. 06. Minetime. Ups. Minetime. Ey, ich kann den mal tippen. Bam. Would you like to integrate
home test with you? No. Elektron. Please. Hinfort. Heutzutage braucht man für eine publische
Kalenderanwendung Elektronen. Äh ja, wir haben die Euler akzeptiert. Caldav, Beta, Username,
Admin. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Server-Uhrl. Tja, jetzt wieder die Frage, was man hier nehmen
soll. Ich nehme mal hier die Basic-Uhrl. Vielleicht ist das Ding so clever. Ups. Und
check das. Easy. Was? Please enter a valid E-Mail to continue. Warum? Ernsthaft? Das
macht überhaupt keinen Sinn. Warum soll ich da eine E-Mail verifinieren? Ist das bei
mir lokal gehostet? Blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub blub.
Ready to go. Q-Chat. Du bekommst einen Code, sonst kannst du nichts machen. Äh. Wie wechsle
ich den Tag? Doch, hier. Nice. Der gefällt mir aber auch überhaupt nicht. Manchmal, wisst
ihr, es kommen, es gibt Tage, wo ich mir wünsche, dass mehr Mac OS Software für Windows und
Linux verfügbar wäre. Die haben ordentliche Notiz-Programme, die haben ordentliche Mail-Programme,
die haben ordentliche Programme mit Call of Unterstützung. Ordentliche To-Do-Programme,
also da muss man sagen, das ist schon besser. Allerdings verwende ich Mac halt nicht. Naja.
So, hat dieses Ding jetzt irgendwo Sachen angelegt bei mir auf dem System? Mein Time
oder so. Config. Mein Time. Tatsächlich. Alles weg. Piss dich, Alde. Trash. Moment,
was? Trash. Empty. Weg. So, wartet mal kurz.
So, wieder am Start. Okay Leute, also, ähm, ich finde Nextcloud 16 macht einen ganz guten
Eindruck. Also deutlich besser als 13. Die, ähm, die Zusatz-Apps, ja gut. Ja. Ich meine,
es sollte basic sein, dass man in der Task-App was suchen kann. Moment, haben wir die Notiz-App
ausprobiert, ob man da auch ordentlich drinne suchen kann? Weil das ging das letzte Mal,
glaube ich, auch nicht richtig. Komm her. Hallo. Suche. Hallo. Moment, man kann seine
Notes nicht durchsuchen. Mein Gott ey, was ist das denn? Wer soll das denn benutzen?
Eine Notiz-App ohne Volltext-Suche. Okay, da gab es aber doch irgendwelche Apps dafür.
Fulltext Search, Fulltext Search Booksmark, Fulltext Search Elastic, Fulltext Search Files.
Und hoffe, dass es funktioniert. Settings Search. Fulltext Search. Search Platform. Ach,
da muss ich zusätzlich noch Elastic installieren, oder was? Ich hab, ich hab aber gar kein Elastic
Search irgendwie auf meinem Raspberry oder so drauf. Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich, das
Setup ist wahrscheinlich die Zeit nicht wert. Okay, ich werd', ich verwende den Kram einfach
weiterhin als stinknormales Dropbox-Ersatz und sonst nix. Und selbst da, weil ich hab
mir nämlich überlegt, der Grund, warum ich, äh, also, der Hauptgrund eigentlich, warum
ich mir das jetzt nochmal angucke, ist, ich hab die Auswahl zwischen Nextcloud, halt als
Lösung, die ein bisschen mehr kann, nebar FileSync und Kalender, oder ich nehm SyncThing
plus, ähm, ein Kalender-Server und gut ist. Wozu ich tatsächlich gerade tendiere? Kann
man eigentlich jetzt hier ein TrueIo-Bild machen? Hallo MrRampage67. Gucken, vielleicht
ist es doch recht einfach einzurichten. Leute seid ihr noch da? Der Chat ist so ruhig.
Was ist da los? Okay, geht anscheinend noch. Elastic Search. Okay, man muss, man muss,
äh, Elastic Search noch zusätzlich installieren. Ne, das ist mir zu blöd. Da hab ich jetzt
gerade nervt drauf. Okay, und wie verwandelt man TrueIo da drinnen? Wahrscheinlich ein
File anlegen, mit der richtigen Extension. Okay, super, super Beschreibung, wie man
es verwendet. Aha, oben auf plus drücken, okay. Plus, Diagramm, aha, blub. Charts, Network,
ja, erzeug Diagramm. Okay, das ist ganz nett, dass sie nen TrueIo-Plugin haben. Was wird
gemacht? Wir haben gerade Nextcloud installiert und ich wollte mir anschauen, ob mir jetzt
Nextcloud 16 gefällt. Ich hab ja aktuell 13, was so ein paar Probleme hat und mir nicht
so zusagt. 16 gefällt mir deutlich besser. Wobei das an vielen Stellen auch irgendwie
noch so ein bisschen unstrukturiert wirkt alles. Okay, haben wir ausprobiert, ist ganz
okay. Das zum testen läuft auf nem Raspberry, allerdings in Zukunft wirds auf ne x86 Kiste
laufen, wenn ichs denn verwende. So wie das aktuelle, was ich hab auch. Der Raspberry
ist mir einfach zu lahm für sowas. Und der O-Troid, der liegt bei mir rum. Das ist ja
dieses kleine Ding in diesem Festplattenrahmen drinnen, der liegt auf dem Sofa hier hinten,
aber da mach ichs nicht drauf. Ne, der Raspberry ist mir zu lahm für sowas. Generell ist der
Raspberry eigentlich für die meisten Sachen, mit denen man viel arbeitet zu langsam. Oder
halt nicht zu langsam, aber so, dass es nervt, wenn du beim Neustarten dann irgendwie 30
Sekunden warten musst, bis Home Assistant gestartet ist und sowas. Das ist blöd. MrRampage
fragt, das ist ne sehr gute Frage. Der MrRampage fragt nämlich das hier. Max, weißt du eigentlich,
wie man bei einem Unity Media, DS Lite, es ist übrigens DS Lite, weil es für Duals
Deck steht, aber es ist, also es hat nix mit DSL in dem Fall zu tun. Anschluss von außen
erreichbar werden kann. Gibt's mehrere Varianten. Über IPv6 bist du schon jetzt erreichbar
von außen, weil du ne IPv6 Adresse hast. Also, es kann sein, dass das in dem Router
irgendeine Firewall drin ist, die das blockt, aber rein adressierungstechnisch bist du mit
IPv6 von draußen jetzt schon erreichbar. Möchtest du allerdings mit deiner IPv4 Adresse
erreichbar sein, dann wird es etwas komplizierter, weil es so pauschal erstmal gar nicht funktioniert.
Weil dein Provider tunnelt deinen kompletten IPv4 Traffic über IPv6, deswegen nennt sich
das ja auch Duals Deck Lite, über deinen kompletten IPv4 Traffic über deinen IPv6
zu Unity Media. Du hast gar keine öffentliche IP, du hast ne private IPv4 Adresse, gehst
zu Unity Media und Unity Media hat dann ein paar Ausgangsserver, die sich lustigerweise
After nennen, die du dir teilst mit, keine Ahnung, 100 Leuten oder so. Das heißt, über
diesen Weg kommst du definitiv nicht von außen an deinen Rechner zum Beispiel. Es gibt
mehrere Varianten, was du machen kannst. Du kannst dir nen eigenen Tunnel bauen, du könntest
dir, also du könntest dir irgendeinen Anbieter suchen, der so nen 6 zu 4 oder was auch immer
Tunnel macht. Einfacher dürfte es sein, du mietest dir irgendwo nen günstigen Server,
der ne feste IPv4 Adresse hat oder bekommen kann und tunnelt sein Kram da drüber zu dir
nach Hause. So würd ich das wahrscheinlich machen. Also als ich Unity Media hatte und
sie mir das noch nicht wieder eingeschaltet haben, dass ich nen vollwertigen IPv4 Anschluss
habe, hab ich so gemacht, ich hab euch ja schon mal erzählt, ich hab bei so nem super
low budget anbieternden Server, also das waren diese 35 Dollar für ne VM auf Lebenszeit,
aber leider, dass die sowas machen. Und da hab ich so gemacht, ich hab mich dorthin
verbunden per SSH und dort quasi nen Port mit SSH aufgemacht, wo man dann bei mir lokal
auf dem jeweiligen Dienst rausgekommen ist. Also kann man sich das vorstellen, ich hab
mich verbunden von mir auf den Server, der hatte ne feste IPv4 Adresse, hab dann gesagt
SSH-G, also global am Port lauschen und Port weiterleiten dann auf dieser Port bei mir
hin. Und dann hab ich noch nen Auto SSH drumherum gemacht, dass es das auch automatisch wieder
neu aufgebaut hat. Ist im Prinzip nix anderes, wie wenn man sich nen Anbieter ansucht, der
einen Tunnel bauen kann. Ne Fritzbox alleine bringt dir nix, ne? Unity
Media muss dich auch wieder umschalten, dass du ne feste IPv4 Adresse kriegst. Also Unity
Media muss dich dafür von Dualstack Lite auf richtigen Dualstack umschalten. Oder auf
IPv4 only meinetwegen, sonst bringt dir die neue Fritzbox auch nix. Also ich geb zu, das
hat sich jetzt alles ein bisschen kompliziert angehört, aber es ist auch ein bisschen komplizierter.
Unity Media, mit Unity Media geht das nicht, so ohne weiteres. Dass wenn du Dualstack Lite
hast, dass du IPv4 was bei dir weiterleitest. Ja wenn Unity Media dich damit umschaltet,
dann ist wieder was anderes. Wichtig ist, dass du den Dualstack Lite Geschiss loswirrst.
Dann funktioniert das. Ne dünne DNS alleine bringt dir auch nix. Wenn du IPv4 Port weiterleiten
willst und IPv4 bei dir daheim nie ankommt, dann bringt dir auch ne dünne DNS nix. Sollte
das Mieten von einer Fritzbox bei Unity Media dazu führen, dass die dich von Dualstack
Lite auf richtiges Dualstack umschalten, dann bringt das was. Wobei es schon ein bisschen
doof ist, dass man für so ne Basic Funktion 5€ im Monat bezahlen soll. Ich mein ok man
kriegt ne Fritzbox zu, aber weiß nicht ob ich das machen würde. Du kannst aber auch
so machen wie ich. Du gehst denen einfach 2 Monate am Stück auf den Sack und dann lenken
sie vielleicht ein und schalten dich frei. Weil ich hab mittlerweile wieder ne feste
IPv4 Adresse oder ich hab wieder eine Public IPv4 Adresse bei Unity Media. Aber ich hab
die wirklich lange genervt und auch öffentlich auf Twitter genervt, was bei mir halt auch
noch nen gewissen Nachdruck hat, wenn sich das 20.000 Leute immer sehen. Kapparot das
interessiert die meisten Leute auf YouTube leider nicht. Ich hatte mir eigentlich vorgenommen
ich will dieses Jahr ein bisschen mehr Technik Krams auf YouTube machen. Aber wie gesagt
ihr habt gesehen wie viele YouTube Videos dieses Jahr gekommen sind. Da hielst du dir
Grenzen. Ja ok wenns bei dir so einfach funktioniert, dass ich weiß ich hab die 2 Monate genervt.
Ihr könnts ja auf Twitter im Prinzip nachlesen. So Leute wir sind eigentlich fertig soweit.
Ich glaub ich geh jetzt Abend essen. Äh falsches E-Mail Teil. Was ist das für ein Programm
mit dem Regenbogen? Lolcat ist das. Lolcat. Also das Fond, Linux Befehlsnamen. Der Fond
kommt aus Toilet. So heißt das Programm. Und Lolcat macht diese Regenbogen-Geschichte.
Also wir können auch sowas hier machen, sowas wie LolW. Achso und drumrum ist ne Weilschaft.
Brauchst du aber nicht. Das brauchst du nur wenn du es ein bisschen schneller ausgeben
willst. Wenn du das weglässt, hast du das Problem, dass das Ding. Warte mal das macht.
Ok ich dachte das macht das eigentlich schon standardmäßig endlos, aber deswegen hab
ich wahrscheinlich mit der Schleife drumrum umgemacht, dass es das endlos macht. Ok dann
schauen wir mal, wen können wir heute hosten? Wen können wir heute hosten? Filter. Äh German.
Den haben wir da. Ich einfach der Erste immer in dieser Kategorie bin. Plender Modeln lernen.
Super Sonntag Special Stream. Was ist das denn? Oh. Ist das was für uns Leute? Ich
glaub nicht. Die ganzen Weeps hier die sind damit. Das geht nicht. Ich kanns nicht lesen.
Ein bisschen kleiner Text vielleicht. Allerdings macht es mir schon mal sympathisch. Es ist
dot net. Der Typ den du gestern gehostet hast wohnt 10 km vom Jahr. Ich fand den Stream
ganz nice. Ich würde interessieren hat jemand so lange geguckt? Hat er das noch hingekriegt
mit seiner Grafikkarte? Hat das noch funktioniert am Ende? Hat jemand zufällig so lange geguckt?
Android App. Android App ist interessierend. Developing Semantic Release. Was? Ich weiß
ja nicht mal was er überhaupt macht. Der hat ein Kabel abgerissen. Oh. Typescript.
Warum printet er? Ach nee LSIS ist das. Es ist wirklich ein Livestream von seinem 3D
Poker mit einem FPS. CS. Klar. Wir gucken mal der Gelegenheit. Was sind denn so die großen
deutschen Streams? Was gibt es denn da? Ich guck ja eigentlich nix. Trimax von dem hab
ich schon mal was gehört. Schlora von dem hab ich auch schon mal was gehört. Kenn ich
nicht. Das sagt mir irgendwas. Von dem hab ich auch schon mal irgendwas gehört. Die Nigo
den kenn ich. Sagt mir gar nix. Das sagt mir auch. Das ist schon mal gesehen. Take kennt
man natürlich. Kenn ich nicht. Kenn ich auch nicht. Kenn ich auch nicht. Kenn ich auch
nicht. Kenn ich auch nicht. Kenn ich auch nicht. Kenn ich nicht. Kenn ich? Wenigstens
mal einnehmer kennt. Kenn ich nicht. Gut. Kennt man. Kenn ich nicht. Kenn ich. Guck
ich nicht. Sagt mir alles nix. Von dem hab ich schon mal was gehört. Von dem hab ich
auch schon mal was gehört. Den kenn ich auch. Der Name sagt mir auch irgendwas. Rest kenn
ich alle hab ich noch nie was von gehört. Ach der streamt auch. Wie viele Mädels es
mittlerweile auf twitch gibt. Und alles keine boob cam Sachen gibt's. Bin ja begeistert.
Dass sich da normale streams jetzt immer mehr durchsetzen. Okay ansonsten kenn ich keinen
mehr. Das hast du jetzt gesagt. Keine Ahnung. Aber die kenn ich. Die hat der Fabian mal
gehorstet. Das hab ich schon mal gesehen. Ja gut. Ich weiß nicht wen ich horsten soll.
Keine Ahnung. Fällt mir jetzt. Fällt mir jetzt nicht nix ein. Wer ist denn bei ähm.
Komm mal hier discover. Wer ist denn bei wie heißt denn diese Kategorie. Es gibt auch
noch mehr als diese science and technology. Oh hier. Programming. Alter Katze was los.
So. Katze. Chico komm mal her. Komm mal her. Sag dem stream mal hallo. Komm mal her.
Die will nicht. Ich bin der viertgrößte weltweiser. Von der hab ich schon mal irgendwas gehört.
Hab ich glaub ich mal nen konferenz vortrag oder so gesehen. Okay ähm. Ich weiß nicht
wen ich horsten soll. Keine Ahnung. Da horst ich heute keinen. Wenn mir keiner einfällt.
Katze willst du nicht immer dem stream hallo sagen. Kannst mal ne runde brumm ins mikrofon.
Runde schnurren ins mikrofon. Ne diesem abenteuer rumgucken modus. Aber für die bessere emersion
hab ich noch ein bild von der Katze bevor wir ausmachen. Da isser. So leute ich hoffe
euch hat es gefallen. Wir machen jetzt schluss. Wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich morgen wieder.
Aktuell ist ja richtiger streaming streak am start. Bis denn. CU. Achso und falls ihr
noch nicht im discord seid. Könnt ihr mal im discord vorbeigucken. Kommt natürlich gerne
auch auf youtube twitter und natürlich auf twitch selber folgen. Dass ihr immer seht
wenn es was neues gibt. Machts gut. Bis zum nächsten mal tschüss.